[Music]
like I realized it's way more
interesting if like you're the art
project if like don't identify as an
artist be the art just spin as many
plates as possible do all the [ __ ] you
dream about you grow a layer you know if
skin thicker skin but also you just
learned what it is you learn to take it
all in stride you can't believe the
people that say like you're a genius and
you can't believe the people who say
you're an idiot you just do you there's
no [ __ ] help coming I'll be honest
with you no one's coming to help you
make your dreams come true that's up to
you that's Kevin Smith and this is the
retro podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening my name
is rich roll I am your host this is my
podcast welcome or welcome back good to
be with you guys today today very
excited to share an amazing conversation
with filmmaker actor comedian comic book
writer author and host of 8 billion
podcast the one and only Kevin Smith you
know this guy right the darling of the
emergent indie film movement in the
1990s he's the guy behind clerks
Mallrats chasing amy dogma a whole
battery of movies in fact right now he's
shooting another Jay and Silent Bob
movie it's called Jay and Silent Bob
reboot I think it's coming out in
October and I've been a fan of Kevin's
for as far back as I can remember I've
spent countless hours enjoying his
movies probably more hours enjoying his
many many podcast conversations and of
course today we explore his remarkable
career but that's not really the impetus
behind why I wanted to sit down with
Kevin the true motivation behind it was
to explore this episode that occurred in
his life in February of 2018 when he
suffered and survived a massive heart
attack Kevin had a 100% blockage of his
anterior descending artery most commonly
known as the Widowmaker and this is the
type of heart attack that most people do
not survive to see another day Kevin was
lucky enough to survive it and I wanted
to explore this experience with him of
course what it was like what happened
and more importantly the lifestyle
changes that he has adopted in the
aftermath of this experience an
experience that is visited upon many as
I've said many times on this podcast
heart disease is America's number one
killer one out of every three people
suffer a heart attack in their life and
again most people do not survive a
Widowmaker heart attack Kevin did he's
here today to share that story with us
so of course
we talked about the genesis of his
filmmaking career the story behind
clerks his rise to fame from this little
tiny single indie film that he made by
maxing out his credit cards that
ultimately spot ins this amazing career
we talked about his journey as an early
adopter to the podcast medium and the
podcast network that he now owns and
runs but mostly this is an exploration
of Kevin's remarkable transformation in
the wake in the aftermath of his heart
attack we talked about his adoption of a
vegan diet losing 50 pounds and how this
experience has shaped his sense of
himself kevin is nothing if not
entertaining he's incredibly charismatic
super honest I really enjoyed this
conversation and excited to share with
you today so without further ado this is
me and Kevin Smith
super nice to meet you nice to meet you
sir how are you I'm doing good thanks
for taking the time to do it oh my god
no worries any chance to talk about how
kinds of stuff something I never talked
about prior to my health episode but you
get tired of sharing the story mmm no
it's incredibly empowering and
inspirational you know I mean heart
disease is America's number one killer
as they say it's it's something that
that that impacts almost every family
and yeah we're the other either directly
or indirectly
my old man was uh was well he had heart
problems he had a lot of pro he's
diabetic and that was the bullet we were
mostly trying to dodge in my family
growing up and my father and his entire
side of the family were diabetics my
mother we didn't know what her side of
the family was cuz she was adopted so
you know we knew what her adopted family
had but but you know genetically or
whatever we didn't know where she was
coming from she still don't know where
she came from so and as she's gotten
older she's found a host of problems
that like oh I guess that's that's what
came from her biological parents but the
the old man yeah he was he was all sorts
unhealthy most of his life when I was on
the operating table the doctor goes I'm
gonna put stent in you do you know what
that is I said yeah man my mom's got a
stent in her art and he goes oh does
your family have a history of heart
problems I said no man my mother just
has a stent in her heart and my father
died of a massive heart attack aged 67
it was like we got to move fast
so yeah it's it was weird
you would think because of my father and
because of my mother that I would have
kept an eye toward heart health mm-hmm
but you know when I was a kid I was a
cigarette smoker so obviously I didn't I
wasn't thinking then and then you know
even the night I had the heart attack I
wasn't thinking this is a heart attack
so much so that you know I when the
doctor told me in the ER you're having a
massive heart attack my first thought
was like this guy's a [ __ ] quack like
there's no way this is not what a heart
attack feels like I'm not even right hey
and I just can't our idea of what a
heart attack is is clutching your chest
and Fred Sanford in San Fran son we
scream
Elizabeth can you grab your chest and
there's so many other symptoms that they
don't teach you about and which are very
easy to look at I guess they're maybe
they don't impart them because it would
make everybody panic the moment you felt
nauseated you would think oh my god am I
having a heart attack because nausea is
part of it right
heavy sweats which I sweat when I
[ __ ] breathe so like that is a
symptom who knew and stuff and breathing
respiratory like that's what I had miss
mistook it for a respiratory issue
because I couldn't quite catch my breath
right and what we found out was later on
that the el-ad the artery goes across
the front your heart was a hundred
percent occluded which I mean is blocked
I guess with the you know a [ __ ] ton of
cholesterol and so that that blockage
right then and there that's what my man
had to get through with his stent in
order to open that eye and then the
weather don't make her the Widowmaker
the dreaded Widowmaker which sounds so
metal sounds also painful yeah and
that's the thing that I love to impart
to people is like I was never in pain
couldn't quite catch my breath and
because of that blocked el-ad they told
me later on think of like a garden hose
when he folded over and the pressure
builds up and he gets fat on one end
that was pushing down on my heart which
in turn was pushing down in my lungs and
that's why I was identifying it as
respiratory and that's why people drop
dead of these heart attacks left and
right because you don't like God I would
not have ever called an ambulance
like I felt uncomfortable but I was
never like oh this hurts please get me
help like it was just like I don't feel
so good and then I would have [ __ ]
drop dead if they hadn't called the
ambulance and stuff that's how those
heart attacks happened I was always so
surprised going up in time you read
about a relative like drop dead it's a
house that [ __ ] impossible you got a no
heart attacks coming you got a you got
to be able to feel it and you do they
just don't really tell you what to look
for now I know what to look for but
leading up to that have you had spells
or incidents where you haven't had there
was no sort of outward you know I mean I
was always heavy sitting overweight
overweight right and there was one now
in retrospect like after the heart
attack because the doctor my
cardiologist doctor laid
was like do you ever remember feeling
the way that you felt that day is good
that's an important feeling to remember
you're gonna need to if you sense that
in any way shape or form get to a
hospital right as the easily do you
remember as it yeah is now that I think
about it actually felt like I felt it
once before and he goes when I said I
was in Florida down in Sarasota and it
was around this time last year is around
December January or something and we
were shooting this a little horror movie
called the Kilroy Was Here
and at one point my kid was down there
she was in the scenes and at one point
like I went and laid down the trailer so
I was like oh man I feel like it wasn't
indigestion but I felt like I was
blocked like in my esophagus like yeah
I'm no doctor so Here I am trying to you
know give my prognosis but it felt like
I was like my guy to eat too much
Flemming my esophageal past that's what
I thought it was and I was like oh my
god I've clearly smoked too much weed
created way too much mucus for myself
and so now it's uncomfortable and I
would be like I just got to eat hard
food like give me some crackers man
that'll wash it down like in my head it
was just like oh this is in your
esophagus and in your throat on the way
down to the stomach and [ __ ] so I was
like I'm gonna lay down for a minute man
this feels irritating that was the exact
same feeling I'd had night a heart
attack
one other time I was playing this video
game Raven the Redwoods this game that
as part of the this video game series
Call of Duty so they've got a mini
zombie game within the game and so I was
a character in the game they scanned me
in and Kevin Smith was a character so me
and the game creator went to twitch and
streamed like us playing the game for an
hour so right at the end of the hour of
playing the game we're playing in a big
TV and Stefan's a first-person shooter
so you're moving around real fast and
whatnot he is I'm not good at that kind
of [ __ ] so as I'm sitting there playing
game like three four minutes left to the
entire thing
a live stream suddenly I feel like
really nauseated and I was like hey man
where's the nearest bathroom he goes oh
we're almost done and I was like I know
I just I gotta go like right now and he
goes out the door across the hallway
jumped off camera got outside the door
which was like from here to that door
only about like five six feet away got
into the hallway it felt like I was
about to vomit and pass out at the same
time went into the bathroom immediately
went down on the floor like I'm purposed
by choice and laid down trying to get
like some my bearings under me like I
just felt a way that I'd never felt in
my life
and how long before the heart attack was
that that was months couple months
before so when I got up I got threw up a
little
nothing like chunky bah chunky but it
was just bile fluid and after I threw up
it felt a little better so when I got
out of the bathroom they're like are you
okay and I was like yeah man that was
[ __ ] up like I was on the bathroom
floor and stuff and then I threw up and
now I feel better and the folks there
were like oh well you'll play games very
often do you I said no they're like you
have motion sickness mmm and I was like
oh is that right they're like yeah
motion sickness manifests itself as the
body thinking it's being poisoned so you
threw up so I think you know if you
don't play games that can happen a lot
man you know we were moving pretty fast
and it all made sense I was like oh my
god that's of course and they play video
games for a living so they would know
this and this is plausible now in
retrospect was probably at 98 percent
occlusion and I was going through a
heart attack like episode or whatever
they call him the [ __ ] tremors in
advance of the heart attack yeah so they
were gonna have the heart attack that
was that was big now I can associate
what that was going oh that's what it
felt like and now knowing what's going
on in my body thanks to a medical
professional I can kind of extrapolate
and go like alright if I was at a
hundred percent blockage than I did my
heart attack
maybe I was at 98 percent blockage that
night and maybe I was at like 95%
blockage the other point and that was my
body trying to say like [ __ ] something
bad is going on here but I wasn't smart
enough to put it together which is in
turn really stupid because I come from
two heart
Nadja with that that's not the
traditional idea of true but I should
give a little explanation it seems
pretty good like I was like well that
makes sense but like now I should have
been I'm blaming nobody I'm not saying
like this is their fault they gave me
bad info I should have been more alert
to the idea that like you could drop at
any [ __ ] moment your father did like
is he 67 uh-huh and your mom's got heart
problems up the ass which is mixed bad
metaphor but like she's you know that's
in your family it's in your face but in
my head I was like well if anything
happens I'm sure it's not gonna happen
till I'm in my 60s like never occurred
to me in a million years
yeah it could happen to me in my 40s
which is why when it was happening I was
like no no when the doctors like you're
having a massive heart attack oh my god
this guy's an idiot he's a quack but I
was he was right I was wrong so what we
walk me through the day you were taping
your special yeah I was doing evening
what was called silent but deadly
yeah the evening with Kevin Smith so
we're essentially normally I go do Q&A
but we're shooting it for comedy
dynamics and with an eye toward you know
Showtime special so the idea in those I
guess is that you shoot two shows in a
night right she's like one at 7:00 one
at 9:00 and then you combine the two
shows make the special so you look the
same in both episodes the audience is
different and if they're good at their
jobs you know the audience never really
notices the home viewing audience never
really notices that hell is cut from two
shows I only say that because I only
shot one show that night it's a low-key
way of bragging about how my entire
comedy special was only show a cut from
one show so in any event we shot the
first show that day I smoked a bunch
didn't do anything really strenuous or
anything like that I was a huge milk
drinker in those days so I drank a lot
of milk I used to drink about two
gallons of milk a day probably why I had
a heart attack probably had a lot to do
though that is an awful lot of cow so uh
I remember I talked to my wife and she
was like do you want me to go because it
was in Glendale and I was like I mean
you know you've seen me talking [ __ ]
zillion times only if you want to go and
she was like I lost hang out here so
drove into the - Glendale you know I'd
smoked a bunch when I got there smoked
more then we did this show everything
went off without a hitch then I got
offstage and chit-chatted with like some
people over there a lady from Showtime
talked to Brian who was directing it and
stuff he was like it was great
he's go we had almost got the whole
thing from that one too bad we got to do
a second show I was like now I got a
hold two hours where the different [ __ ]
I'm ready to go so I went into the green
room and I there's milk there a glass
bottle a nice
so I cracked it open took a big thing a
milk big drink and then I was suddenly
fairly nauseated
my first thought was like if somebody
[ __ ] pissed in the milk or something
like the milks been [ __ ] with like the
you know it's got to be bad milk I think
I've just had some bad milk so I felt
weird and I asked Jordan who runs our
company and Emily who does my hair
makeup I was like hey man can I have the
room like cuz when I'm sick I don't want
to be around people I just want to go
off and [ __ ] die like an animal so I
said can I have the room I don't feel
that well and they were looking at
totally and they stepped out and I laid
down on the floor always kiss on kids if
you're laying down the floor in public
get a doctor yeah so there I'm I'm
laying down on the floor feel nauseated
feel hot and I throw up bile and then I
feel a little better then Emily comes in
and she's like are you okay and I was a
get can you turn on the hairdryer and
just drive me off like I'm sweating
profusely and stuff so she's like yeah
totally so she sits me in the chairs
puts the hairdryer on me and she's
drying my hair you know she feels my
neck and she goes you know this is gonna
sound creepy but I feeling your neck all
the time for Ford Walton junior never
felt this before you're freezing cold on
your neck like you sure you may be
something we should look into I was like
yeah I don't feel great I was like I'm
gonna I need a couch somebody find a
couch this is at the theater the Alex
Theatre in Glendale so Jordan found a
couch on has a guy just gonna lay down
here for a while man which is like you
know
now again knowing what happened like
that's how [ __ ] people die you know
I'm like I'm just gonna lay down I don't
feel good I'm gonna lay down and you
know meanwhile my heart was [ __ ]
attacking me or I'm you know fair enough
I had attacked it most of my life with
all the [ __ ] I ate so the heart was like
turnabout's Fair Play so I'm laying on
this couch and I can't get comfortable
flip around and stuff which is weird cuz
I could fall asleep the drop of that so
then there's a chair there so I went
into the chair and sat in it and then
put my arms above my head to facilitate
breathing because I couldn't quite catch
my breath or like no like tightness in
your chest no not no arm no you know
they tell you like your left arm your
right arm goes numb it's gonna feel like
an elephant sitting on it just none of
that [ __ ] just couldn't quite like catch
my breath this is a normal breath up to
the top then I could only go and I
couldn't ring the bell I can I get it
all the way up to the top so I put my
hands above my head as raising them up
like this like you know like a like a
football referee try facilitate
breathing and so I'm sitting in the
chair and Jordan kind of creeps in
around the corner she goes you're
alright I was like I feel really [ __ ]
up I've never felt like this before in
my life I was like maybe I should see a
doctor she's like well we cancelled the
second show and I was like why would you
cancel the second child and she was like
I've never seen you be sick before this
is really weird so call off the second
show there's a guy right well if the
show's called off and I felt okay
because Brian said he could cut
everything out of one so as a guy were
covered there I was like if the show is
called the called off maybe I should go
see a doctor right now she goes it's
Sunday night there and the doctors open
so I called an ambulance and I was like
why the [ __ ] would you call an ambulance
man oh my god this is embarrassing like
they're gonna show up they're gonna tell
me I smoked way too much weed and stuff
like don't why would you do that she's
like better safe than sorry I didn't
know what to do
so I'm sitting there in the chair of my
arms up and all of sudden like and when
you call the ambulance fire department
comes as well so six brawny asked fire
firefighters come in the room and there
I am sitting there and chair of arms up
one of them young enough to like be like
five [ __ ] no this guy is and he's
looking at me like why ssambap
celebrating a touch
then I was like hey and they were like
you alright I said yeah just I can't
quite catch my breath two paramedics
come in guy and a girl the Bobbsey Twins
I'm a guy goes hi which name is Kevin
Smith he goes mr. Smith how you feeling
mr. Spence my father and he goes oh I've
heard that joke before he goes uh what's
going on I can't quite catch my breath
he goes alright let's see what's going
on here I'm gonna get blood pressure
cuff on you put a cuff on me starts
pumping it and then the lady's got this
what looks like a fishing tackle box and
she opens it up it's got leads and wires
in it and stuff I'll since grabs my
[ __ ] hockey jersey Yanks it up and
every one of my titties and guts falls
out I'm like oh and she's like what
what's the matter I can't get right back
down so don't do that there's a bunch of
people around here she's like I get
these wires on you and I was like well
I'll hold my shirt out you just reach
under it and use my nipples as
guideposts it's like but don't lift my
shirt up and she looks at the other guy
she's like we ain't got time for this
and the guy goes mr. Smith I need you to
do me a favor open your mouth and open
my mouth because I lift your tongue I
did he's gonna put something in it so
okay and he sprayed something under my
tongue and they said close your mouth
and it did and I remember thinking like
this is so [ __ ] weird your whole life
your parents train you like if a
stranger says to you open your mouth
I'll put something in it you [ __ ] say
no but because dudes wearing uniform I
was like aha
just totally let him do whatever he
wanted so the guy goes he looks at
ladies fishing tackle box which is now
wires touch my chest and I didn't think
anything of it right like they're moving
faster paramedics and stuff I'd seen
paramedics work before but I'd never
bent the receiving end of them so the
guy goes you know what we're gonna take
you for a ride to the hospital and I was
like oh my god please don't do that this
is embarrassing I honestly just smoked
way too much weed today he goes yeah
that could be the case he's gone but
we're so close better safe than sorry
man we're gonna take you to the hospital
you ever been in the hospital before I
was like no he goes oh you're gonna love
it
as it really goes yeah man we're taking
an ambulance you ever been in ambulances
no egos we'll even ring the siren that's
like I know let's [ __ ] do it they put
me in this chair that becomes a bed that
becomes a gurney right it's like a
transformer yeah but in order to get me
there that's what a fireman come into it
so I go
get up and like whoa you stay right
there and they bring the six firemen
over and they're like all right pick him
up
dudes put their hands under me in six
[ __ ] brawny ass firemen lift me to
the ground was most fun I had like in
the last year because nobody ever tries
to pick my ass up like I was fun I was
like whee they put me in the chair and
[ __ ] got me upstairs as I was being
wheeled out there's bunch of people
lined up for the next show
and I guess they'd been informed that I
was not having a second show because I
was suffering from food poisoning
somebody had heard that I threw up said
like oh it must be food poisoning so
that's what they told everybody he can't
do the second chair he's got food
poisoning and as I'm leaving there's
somebody you know a bunch of people
outside they're all clapping like way to
go keV and then there was one guy who's
making the universal face for sticking
his finger down his throat you know the
vomiting face but I didn't know that
they were told that I puked and I wasn't
honestly thinking about that I was so
like what the [ __ ] I'm in an ambulance
now I saw a dude pointed his finger in
his mouth and I was like this [ __ ]
man telling me suck his dick as I'm
being put in an ambulance like where's
the decency and [ __ ] like that you know
wheeled out in front of all your fans to
Olli and I was like waving to him and
stuff like the Queen they put me in an
ambulance
I go to Glendale Adventist and that
wasn't the name of the hospital on the
call sheet since we were shooting we
were in production there's a call sheet
for every production call sheet has a
bunch of useful information on including
where to go in case of a medical
emergency this is the hospital we've
designated as the production hospital
the ambulance didn't take me there they
take me to Glendale Adventist which is a
little further away but because the
medics knew what was happening and they
knew that Glendale Adventist was a
fantastic cardiac Hospital mm-hmm so I
get there they bring me into the ER
that's where I meet dr. Layton I'm Marc
late night guy saves my life comes in
he's like hi how you doing I said I'm
good I just can't catch my breath he
goes well how's your pain you know on a
level of zero to ten what can't pay me
and I was like negative three and he
goes oh oh well then you're doing this
all wrong I said what do you mean he
goes if you're having a massive heart
attack you're supposed to be in pain as
I'm having a massive heart attack he
goes you sure are right now you don't
know that I was like no no but it wasn't
it the first first time he was
communicated to me in the emergency room
where I was like
what the and he goes so we're gonna move
fast cuz what I think it is we got to
get there as quickly as possible so I'll
see you upstairs and he leaves and
another guy comes in with a bucket a
razor and he goes okay in order for the
doctor to get up to your heart we gotta
go through your grind so I'm gonna need
to shave your grind so can you take off
your shorts then so I take off my jean
shorts and then I leave my underwear on
because I'm like I take my underwear off
in the emergency room dick out in the
emergency room like I'm seeing I've been
to the emergency room before with other
people and it's a mess
and once you're done looking at the
person you're there with once they're
stabilized or whatever the [ __ ] once you
look around you're like oh my god people
in various states of undress and whatnot
can't help but see room so I'm sitting
there going I [ __ ] take them
underwear off like that forget it
like all I need is one person with a
[ __ ] cell phone camera be like Silent
Bob's dick and I'm ruined for life so
I'd say the guy goes you got to take
your underwear off and I was like ah why
and he goes because I got shaved her
groin and I said what what's the groin
to you and he goes it's where your leg
meets your body what are you talking
about is like I don't well that's the
case I'll pull my underwear to the side
and you just get in there and do virgin
smoothie Atlantic death and you're
negotiating over like because I was
ashamed of my dick like God's got bye he
goes what are you doing why are you
talking as I said look man I got a small
dick I got body shame issues and [ __ ]
obviously and that man just told me I
had a heart attack and if you make me
take off my underwear in front of all
these people I will have a second heart
attack and that's gonna be on You Man so
let's do this
and he goes fine just pull him over to
pull underwear over any shape it was I
think they were just like how amusing
well he's gonna die anyway let's go so
they got me upstairs and the first thing
to a doctor let him I'm 7 they brought
me and he goes why is he still wearing
his underwear and the guy who pushed me
and goes he's got a story
he's got body shame issues and I said
yeah doc my dick is real small and the
doctor he goes mean got time for this he
Yanks my [ __ ] underwear off my body
like I'm a heroine in a 70s porn movie
and stuff so I was trying to fight to
keep my hockey jersey on cuz hockey
jersey is like a muumuu and it covers
everything and stuff so I was like I can
keep my Jersey I'll cover my dick at
least even if he's going at my groin you
don't need to see my dick nothing
people need to see my dick so I'm like
he's like take that shirt off him and I
go no I need that man this is my lucky
hockey jersey like you know even though
I'm drugged I didn't know this I was
drugged at this point they started
feeding me fentanyl they have to because
they're gonna [ __ ] puncture your body
and your groin cut a hole into you and
then feed a [ __ ] tube up your femoral
artery so naturally they don't want you
feeling anything so moment they start
this [ __ ] and be like [ __ ] yo so they
drug you with fentanyl I didn't know
this so I think I'm being keen and
clever and [ __ ] like coming up with a
lie about having to wear my [ __ ]
hockey jersey and [ __ ] because it's my
lucky hockey jersey and really I was
drugged and I didn't know that till
after I was coming out of the operating
room my wife is just like are you okay
and I said you know what that's a heart
attack now take [ __ ] five more that
was easy man and she goes you must be on
drugs I was like no they didn't give me
any drugs whatsoever I was sober that
whole time and she said the doctor was
behind me and he goes he's on a lot of
fentanyl like right now so they're pump
me full of fentanyl and even though I
was drugged it was like I gotta keep
this Jersey on it's my lucky hockey
jersey and the doctor is like if it's so
lucky why are you having a heart attack
get that off and they took off all my
clothes and I was laying there I was
like you have your will of me that was
the thing that was I was more scared of
than the heart attack it was being
completely naked yeah that vulnerability
oh my god your image issues so strong
that literally on the operating table
I'm willing to die for it at that point
and these cats like are looking at me
like what do you [ __ ] dumb or
something and I don't obviously don't
understand how in jeopardy I truly was I
now have long since like I've met many
and of course dr. mark explained later
on but like I wanted to get a check-up
for the movie we're about to make we
make Jay and Silent Bob reboot this year
and so before you make a movie since I'm
the writer and I'm one of the stars and
the director and [ __ ] like that I'm a
key man they make you go in and get top
to bottom me and fire looked at they got
unsure to move in you're the one they're
insuring so I went in and saw dr. Paula
who I see for like every movie and stuff
like that and you know she was on me as
well she's like is what's all this I
heard about the ARDS I said yeah we
don't make her a couple months back but
it worked out a lost bunch of weight and
stuff and she goes you don't know
how lucky you are sigh I know I've heard
it very very lucky she goes no you have
no idea how lucky you are she's like
when I was an internist I was in surgery
with another doctors and his forties
been three other doctors in the room
working on this patient it's going so
we're in a hospital room lots of doctors
lead surgeon drops to the ground has a
massive Widowmaker our detect just like
you know and I was like whoa and she
goes well if you're gonna have our
attack best place to have it is in an
operating room surrounded by doctors I
was like this right so you saved him she
goes nope couldn't it's gone that
Widowmaker she's going there's just no
telling she's like it's not even 50/50
as you urge he's leagues 8020 most
people just go and if you're male in
your 40s you're very susceptible to this
she's going so we couldn't save that guy
the fact that you walked away from this
you have no idea and stuff I was like
well you know they gave me the stents
and she goes it goes beyond that it's
beyond just like the occluded like el-ad
and the stench going like for some
reason we don't know why but male heart
becomes susceptible to this particular
type of heart attack throughout the
whole corridor you're 40 she's like he
almost got out yeah because I was 47 and
she's gone but it happens you gotta look
out for it well maybe nobody tells us
that yeah there maybe there's something
to that hockey jersey you know what I'm
sayin it was lucky who knew so he went
up he was sitting there he punctured
into my groin fed the tube up
he's chit-chatting with me the whole
time I was singing old times I was like
[ __ ] hyped up hopped up on veteran
doesn't know I had no idea so I singing
the theme song to Degrassi junior high
which is whatever it takes I know I can
make it through Grassi the next
generation very hopeful song so he goes
alright
I'm there and yes it's what I think it
is he goes you got 100% of clusion or
el-ad I said what is that he goes you're
the big artery goes right around in
front of your heart
biggest important artery is all blocked
with cholesterol can't get any blood
through man so we're gonna have to put a
stent in there and so he [ __ ] said
like you know do you know he's ghost
your comic book guy I said yeah and he
goes they call this heart attack the
Widowmaker and I said oh really and he
goes yeah this is all wall right before
he heads back into my surgery
he goes yeah man because in 80% of the
cases of a hundred percent occlusion
like you got now the patient's always
dies but you're gonna be in the 20% so
I'm great at my job and they disappeared
into my crotch and like made magic and
stuff so I sat there thinking about like
oh [ __ ] this is it this is the closest
I've ever come as far as I know maybe I
come closer but I never knew nobody ever
said like [ __ ] you got a 20% chance
chance of living right now so those are
the lowest odds ever had known as I came
in this could be it this is if this dude
isn't good at his job
you're gonna shuffle loose the mortal
coil so start thinking spent your whole
life analyzing yourself with your head
up your own ass wondering about you
trying to figure out who you are you are
like what do you think now like here it
is this is the big moment but we've been
terrified your whole [ __ ] life what
do you what's going through your mind so
I was raised Catholic and I was an altar
boy and stuff and I said well maybe I
should pray and then I was like you know
what that ain't gonna work cuz I'm sure
I'd pray and then the Lord would be like
you made dogma go [ __ ] yourself and so I
wouldn't get any out there so I did not
from that God yes I didn't scofflaw I
wasn't some scofflaw turning to God as a
last resort I said why would I presume
upon the wonderful fictional friendship
like that so I just started thinking
about my life in general and I thought
about my parents and what an amazing job
they did raising me as a kid like you
know as the third in the line they
didn't know what they were [ __ ] doing
they had no money whatsoever and somehow
it worked out like and they put me on
this weird journey that resulted in me
like having a very cool job for many
many years and like finding a wife and
getting married having a kid in my own
like having a family and stuff like I
thought about my friends my brothers and
sister my brother and sister all my
friends Jason you know everybody that
like put me where I am or helped me get
there as part of my life and stuff and I
was I don't know there was this odd
sense of calm instead of being like oh
god I'm gonna miss this or I'm [ __ ]
mad at the world for dying and [ __ ] my
big takeaway was this is okay it felt
like graduation day honestly for me
about my amazing life I don't even know
gotten to do so many things there's
definitely a sense of like American
satisfaction like I've done I've checked
a lot of boxes or whatever and I'm sure
this story would be different if I was
like so there I was getting eaten by a
[ __ ] shark or you know there I was
getting a corn and draw drawn and
quartered by an angry mob I'm sure I
would have a different perspective of
death store but there I was hopped up on
fentanyl in an operating table uh-huh
and I was filled with a sense of calm I
was filled with like well this is this
makes sense like it felt like high
school like when I graduated high school
I was like well this is sad because now
this part of your life is over but this
is the journey like this makes sense
this is an ending and now you'd start
something else so I wasn't scared or
nervous or you know long yeah save me
doc I did say to him at one point doc if
you can save my life he goes I'll try
but I was never like panicky and I
thought I chalked that up to being like
stoned on weed because I was like smoke
so much weed that well the fentanyl to
know that really I was like this is fine
I'll just hang here in the netherworld
it was it was weird a weird sense of
completion like oh yeah this is what
you're supposed to do like you know we
spend so much of our lives terrified of
that moment of like letting go of like
this it all ends and we don't know what
happens over there and you know what if
it's a yelling [ __ ] chasm of [ __ ]
the bodyless souls that just eat you and
tear you apart in the darkness or what
if it's heaven like nobody knows so as i
sat there all of a sudden I was filled
with a sense of calm of like no this
makes senses was supposed to happen like
I thought about there's a Public Enemy
song he got game from like 1998 and at
the end Flavor Flav is doing what Flavor
Flav does and he talks through the end
of the song and stuff and he says one of
the lines is fairly profound he says
look inside yourself for peace give
thanks live life and release and it felt
like oh that makes sense now this is the
release point like holding on to it
maybe it's not gonna help just let it go
you're done and yeah it's early
47 is young but like [ __ ] you've done a
lot so if this is the end of the party
don't be the [ __ ] who's like you know
hey man let's go out for pizza at 4 a.m.
and should just [ __ ] go home like you
did it but in fairness you've lived a
life of fewer regrets compared to the
average human like you've turned over a
lot of stones you've lived a life that
you've wanted to live and we'll the
turning over of stones doesn't always
lead to satisfaction you lose a lot of
regret as well so you know it's it's I
don't altima Lee have regret about the
things that I do or you know or the path
that I've taken because it always leads
you to the next thing and whatnot but
there's definitely moments of like I
thought I wanted this so bad and then
life shows you that maybe you didn't
want this at all but in moments like
that I try to honor the kid that started
the journey like because it's never me
who's paying the price or receiving the
accolades right like it's it's me it's
this current version of me not the
heroic kid who was like I'm gonna try to
do something that I've never done before
I'm gonna try to make a movie I'm living
on that kids coattails rest of my
[ __ ] life I personally have never had
to do anything that kid [ __ ] kicked
open the doors and started me rolling so
I always try to honor that kid even as
far removed as I am from that kid at
this moment in time and so I always ask
myself or say to myself two things after
every triumph or failure but normally
you need to say this more in times of
quote-unquote failure and to be honest I
don't believe it's real failure failure
is not doing the thing but in moments
where it's like this didn't succeed the
way I wanted to the two things I say to
myself are just like well you wanted
this like oh my god did you want this
you changed everything to make this
happen you made people uncomfortable
like they were comfortable in their own
lives and you had them leave and come
join you in another place to [ __ ]
make pretend and stuff you changed the
[ __ ] universe to make this happen you
went out and found a [ __ ] ungodly
amount of money to make pretend and now
you're gonna sit here and say that like
maybe you didn't know you [ __ ] wanted
this you better [ __ ] enjoy it
[ __ ] enjoy it and never sell out
on it and then the other thing I always
tell myself is like what was the
alternative like seriously it seems like
right now like you're regretting this
but
what was the alternative if you didn't
do this you would sick you sit there and
it would eat you up inside like a
[ __ ] cancer you'd be sick over the
fact that like I wonder if I should have
I wonder if I could have I want to do
that thing and [ __ ] like that and then
to not honor it when you've got the
ability to follow through and you've got
the means to do so like you know how to
make your dreams come true and once you
once you see that you can't ever be like
now that's impossible you know how to do
the impossible so [ __ ] you like there
was no alternate right so the regrets
the regrets aren't from not taking
advantage of the opportunities they
exactly like when I set that on the
table I was now I had no regrets about
passing out of this world I was like you
know what [ __ ] you did it like you're
getting out of here man and [ __ ]
you're graduating well done it but the
one kind of regret that I had was I was
laying there going like man if I die
tonight the last movie I made was yoga
hosers and I took a lot of [ __ ] for that
movie so I was like if I could just make
it to one more move if I can make Jay
and Silent Bob reboot you know then at
least that would make sense to end on
that movie right so that's why I'm like
I got to get to that movie as quickly as
Bob did it shuffle the deck on your
sense of priorities at all or did you
feel like I got that in check you would
think that it was like ah now my eyes
are open there was no Bill Murray at the
end of Scrooge type moment because I
think I live my life like Bill Murray at
the end of Scrooged like you know I'm
constantly in a state of Revelation
constantly sharing that revelation with
with the world some people like me and
in media podcast mega movies whatever
the [ __ ] it's not enough for us to
experience something like most people
most people live their lives and
experience it and they're [ __ ] happy
doing that happy having those
experiences maybe they share them with
some friends and [ __ ] like that but then
there's [ __ ] like me they were like
oh I have to tell you the experience
that I have the world needs to know
because we think the world gives a [ __ ]
what we say or bla bla bla so I've
always kind of lived that guy's life
like the life of like let me tell you
what I learned and [ __ ] like that
and because of that there's really no
like sense of like you know
the Scrooge on Christmas morning going
go get me a goose boy like I've seen
three ghosts and now I get it
I always got it yeah and not not that
like I get it and others don't
I've always gotten what I wanted to get
our life so being that close to death it
wasn't like [ __ ] man now you got to
change everything if anything it just
made me go like thank God I did as much
[ __ ] as I did because apparently I'm not
gonna live a very long life so now if
anything it just makes me go like all
right we are given to do is more we got
to do even more and I've always done as
much as humanly [ __ ] possible you
used to be just the movies like I'm
gonna make movies I'm a filmmaker and
then I got kind of not boring but just
like it happens every two years like
what do I do with all this [ __ ]
downtime and that's where like
everything else came in like the comic
books are standing on stage and talking
or the podcasts or later on the TV show
all was an effort to like fill that time
because I realized early on like this is
it the great and secret show ends and
then you [ __ ] die do as much as you
can before the [ __ ] curtain falls so
when I was laying on that table and
thinking like this is it I was filled
with a sense of like well I'm done I
finished I've done a lot of stuff yeah
live Leno give thanks live life and
release and then when I was spared and
suddenly I'm here I'm like alright let's
just triple the output cuz I get it now
it was what I always suspected no good
way out of this life and I was at the
door of probably the best way out of
this life I was hopped up on [ __ ]
fentanyl singing to Grassi with no
[ __ ] regrets in my life you know if I
had gone out [ __ ] that would have been
wonderful but I didn't so now I just
want a triple the output because I
realized there's a we're just the
smartest [ __ ] bears on the planet
that's it
you know at the end of the day it's like
this is we look around at other species
and like you know we feel like we are
[ __ ] in control like we are the
Masters and we are certainly heads and
shoulders above all these other animals
like I you know I was raised in the
Catholic Church and there was never any
sort of like well yeah we love all life
but we eat lambs and even though there's
a picture of Jesus holding the lamb he
probably ate it later on because we've
got a very complicated relationship with
animals and [ __ ] like that and really
what I realized was we're just we're
just the clever ones we're
the only difference between us in the
animal kingdom is we know how to tell a
story and worse than that we know how to
buy into a story case in point you got a
dog try to explain the concept of a $20
bill to my dachshund Shecky yeah you
know maybe she'll try to bite at it and
[ __ ] like that but like that's a story
we agree on here's money I'm gonna give
you this piece of paper and that says
that I have wealth and that some of that
wealth is now yours and I'm exchanging
it for goods and services
it's a [ __ ] story like a very
delicate story that like you know
currently the reality we live in we're
seeing the the very threads of that
reality tugged at being tested yeah but
the the foundations of civilization are
built on these agreed-upon myths stories
social contract
yeah it's fundamentally an illusion and
that's that's what I got out all this I
was like well it's all fundamentally
illusion and there's really no sense to
it and it's only through luck and
evolution and timing that your species
wound up [ __ ] on top with the ability
to be like Romeo Romeo where far out
thou Romeo just lean in like make
pretend for your entire [ __ ] life you
know it occurs to me every once in a
while like should I be a more serious
person and should I understand politics
should I look into government should I
you know just anything that like my
serious peers and people that I went to
school with or you know people who are
now adults and like pursuing careers
they went after like the noble work and
the real work and [ __ ] like that the
[ __ ] you read about in books when you
were in school this one's a doctor this
one's a lawyer this one's this and [ __ ]
and I chose the thing that you know is
like the grasshopper in the ants story I
chose grasshopper I'm like oh my god I'm
gonna [ __ ] fritter away all my days
and [ __ ] here's my fiddle I'm gonna go
nuts I'm gonna try to entertain you and
myself and [ __ ] and when I was faced
with my ultimate demise and like my
mortality I didn't walk away from that
gone well now now I understand like it
just made it more clear like keep
playing right till the rain there's no
there's no there's far as I know it's
just us and that's it and this story
that we keep telling ourselves and the
story gets more and more complicated as
centuries go on and stuff but so far so
good we're the biggest scam artists on
the planet the human race
it's a cynical way to look at it it's a
positive way hasn't injected in you any
kind of sense of greater you know
spiritual awareness or anything like
that
none whatsoever now no in fact I
probably not even now I would never say
that oh my god I'm insanely hopeful I'm
a very positive person I was cross we're
here we're doing our thing well I mean I
was raised on pack lies unfortunately
and so that [ __ ] you up for child
throughout your adulthood as well like
and I'm not blaming the Catholic Church
I'm blaming my parents but you got to
understand how twisted my insides are
for years I was told there was a Santa
Claus and I was like yeah of course that
makes sense a stranger will bring us
presents he's a friend of God's because
I was also Catholic and then one day my
parents were like Santa's not real
we've just been saying that to you for
years because that's what you do with
kids I'm sorry we're part of that but
yeah it's time to let that go what about
God well God's very was that traumatic
for you no no it wasn't it wasn't like
I'm losing Santa but it was confusing
for me because I got to keep God lost
Santa
they were like Santa's not real don't be
ridiculous god that's real and you know
you sit there gone like well I have zero
proof of God just like I have zero proof
of Santa Claus
like in fact there are more renderings
for Santa Claus we want to look for an
image there's a bunch out there and
stuff but I was expected to hold on to
God and I did up until the time I made
dogma and then I was like you know I met
George Carlin and George Carlin was like
you believe all this stuff and I was
like of course you were raised Catholic
don't you [ __ ] know I'm smarter than
that and that's when I started thinking
so it was Carlin that turned you Carlin
and Scott Mosier and not turned me but
just kind of taught me to use a
different organ you know usually used my
brain differently Scott Mosier two years
of doing SModcast and in knowing him his
god produced almonds and stuff he just
made the Grinch movie there's now huge
Scott was always so baffled by my blind
faith in you know there's something
after this of course there is and he was
like why do you think that that was it
because like what would we why would we
bother doing all this like what was a
bit there must I must be going somewhere
after this there must be some reward
good or bad there's no point in living
all this life and then just [ __ ]
dying and sitting in the earth like you
think and he goes why because that's
what we
he's gone like yeah I understand you
believe in something but I think we're
computers and I think once a computer
spins down that's it no computer lasts
forever man eventually it just dies and
all that information that's on that
laptop just [ __ ] dies with it unless
you download it somewhere he's going the
trick is we should learn to download our
art you know intelligence and so that
that way you could live on he's going
but like you know turn a life I don't
buy that and he was never shitty about
it never gone like you're an idiot for
believing this but Scott one of the
smartest people I've ever met in my life
and if Scott couldn't really make the
leap of faith I was sitting there going
maybe there's no leap to make so you
know I started thinking about it more
and more and arrived at Mike own
conclusions about oh you know maybe
Dogma was he trying to work out the last
bit of something that can't possibly
make sense in in the light of day and
something that like as an as a grownup
you can't really put your head around in
the same way I well that's the Lord
calling right now hang like he's gonna
ring you up yeah correct you a little I
wonder if there's a relationship between
and also sorry before we go further I
don't want anyone to think that I'm
taking their faith away from him I just
want you to know I wish I was still you
I wish I could still have the faith that
I had as a kid or even up into my
mid-20s and stuff when I meet people of
faith I'm always weighing to it like oh
my god good for you I just I wish I wish
I had still had that and I'm not saying
I just saw something you people didn't
and stuff unfortunately I just arrived
at a different conclusion I look at it a
little bit differently I mean I think
the more that we learn about science and
the crazier it gets the more I think
there's opportunity for for faith in
something that we can't understand in
the same way that Shecky can't
understand that $20 bill right why do we
think we are so smart
like you said Scott's you know smart
once Mars God's you know totally but
maybe our brains to start big enough to
comprehend what's actually right in
front of us
do you have what we just well something
beyond our ability to comprehend oh I'm
bad I'm I'm I'm all for that but that's
not what the Catholic Church asked no
not Catholicism that's not what any
faith asks you
oh look I'm I'm a into the beyond an
undefined spiritual faith look something
someone we can put someone has
information that I don't and they're
like look here's what you're missing
I'm more than happy to listen to it and
if what their truth is is like none of
these people understand it because
here's the real truth like Grant
Morrison was on the podcast once and
told me what he saw when he like dropped
acid or whatever it was and kind of went
to the top of his hat and like he had
his consciousness kind of exploded and I
was like that sounds awesome if that's
nobody ever presented that as a
possibility like you got your
Catholicism got your Judaism you got
your in do ISM and then you had this
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] where somebody tells
you that you're just a small cog in the
universe of higher consciousness I'm all
for that but that's the first time that
was a presented to me so if you're ready
to present me with like here's another
option I'm so open-minded to that but
the moment you start talking about God
is this what it is well looks like no
I'm not saying that at all right I'm
saying there's an opportunity for for on
wonder out there oh I believe you I'm I
live this I think you don't need faith
to live and awe and wonder and I say
that from a guy who's lived both sides
of the coin is on wondering everything
you look at in nature you don't need God
in your life to see that do you feel
like post heart attack you have a
greater sense or appreciation of that no
no yeah you've kind of gone on record
and said look I didn't have a huge
epiphany I mean you've made changes in
how you live that was the big epiphany
it was like you're being an [ __ ]
living this way but spiritual I've
always been pretty pretty like fulfilled
and living it all out and examining it
my head and my heart not my physical
heart my spiritual heart I spent a lot
of time on in this life yeah my body not
so much now and that is the real wake-up
call cool we're gonna talk about that in
a minute but first I wonder whether
there's a relationship or a connection
between your experience in the growing
up Catholic and your like love for an
appreciation for the myths that you find
in pop culture God not books and you
know those those archetypal figure
and stories that just connect with us so
deeply as humans I like everybody else
loved a morality tale and the Bible is
chock-a-block full of some of the
greatest morality tales ever written and
if you're remotely religious you've
heard of all these great paradigms of
faith and stuff like that
however you know the older I got then I
was introduced to comic books and you
know I was drawn to those stories and of
course they're colorful and they're
programmed for kids you know that
written for you had been that in that
era so naturally makes sense but it was
until I got a little older that I
realized there's a correlation between
these two there's a parallel I love a
good morality story it just so happens
that Marvel and DC told way more
entertaining versions in their funny
books then the Bible didn't it so I have
nothing but respect for anybody that can
weave a tale about how doing the right
thing is the better choice especially in
a world where doing the wrong thing is
the easier choice or in the case of the
comic books the more colorful powerful
choice so yeah those things are
definitely combined definitely related
in my mind it's interesting how your
career has sort of blossomed like hand
in hand like on a parallel track with
culture at large embracing you know this
format like your career starting at that
very special moment where independent
film was blowing up you happen to take a
chance and be there at the right
opportunity for that and just being true
to who you are and and preaching your
love for this you know kind of pop
culture and to have culture then embrace
that in a way that fit you like a glove
and allowed you to like be who you are
I'm like everybody on the Internet
essentially that's what it is like I got
to be that guy first and then if people
had waited two minutes the internet was
going to happen and there would be a
generation of me of people who are like
he jumped I wanna do my own ego I mean I
remember I mean I have to thank you for
inspiring me to you know even go on this
journey because I was a super early
adopter
Cass and I seen your movies and I was an
entertainment lawyer I was at Sunday and
like I've been at Sundance a million
times like I followed your clerk story
from the get-go I worked with at burns
I'm looking for Kitty like I know her
that independent world and I appreciate
you know what you were able to create
and craft out of that thank you but then
I had my own like kind of personal
transformation and I started training
for these crazy ultra endurance races
and I would spend like eight hours
training by myself out on a bike and
like I can't listen to music or I need
something to entertain me but I got into
podcast 2007 like right at the beginning
those are the emotions oh yeah you guys
were from the get-go oh geez February
2007 the people who were there before us
just for context Leo Laporte right and
this week in attack I mean Bill Maher
had a when did real time rock n roll I
started after us after yeah Corolla was
on the radio Adam had a radio show got
canceled and then it got canceled and
then like the next day for the weekend a
started the Adam Carolla podcast so we
were obviously Corolla and a handful
like it was a little bit longer before
Rogan started it was like hobbyists yeah
in these little hard ways there's
another one that's right that's right
but that was but those guys came and
this is not [ __ ] bragging but like
like I remember those dudes joining and
being like oh they have us analogy to do
it yeah why I mean unless you count like
the father the pod father himself is
Adam Curry habla that's right a guy from
MTV totally forgot who did it before
anybody but like but it was it was I
mean you had to be committed to be a
listener because you had to download it
on your desktop you had to bounce it to
an iPod like it was a whole thing yeah
right so you had to get your okay here
are the ones I want to listen to I'm
gonna be on the bike for however many
hours I'm gonna need this much right
listening time and I'd be like I got you
know I got smog cap I got four episodes
of smog cat whatever you know and so I
was listening from the very very
beginning thank you and I thought like I
knew you from the movies but I didn't
know you outside of that and I fell in
love with your voice and your
authenticity and your honor
and just being who you are and I found
that to be very inspiring and it would
be many years later until I started this
thing but I took a lot of inspiration
and spent many hours listening to you
that for a long time the world men think
and you're incredibly you're an
incredibly gifted talented artist but as
a personality just you being you is my
favorite Kevin Smith am I do my thank
you for that yeah mine too that was the
I didn't realize that was the aim in the
beginning I was like I want to be a
filmmaker I want to make films and stuff
that seemed to be the aim and once that
happened I was like right on happily
ever after and I was young and stuff but
then over time and it took a while like
10 years or something like I realized
it's way more interesting if like you're
the art project if like if you take your
life like don't identify as an artist be
the art like now you're doing this now
you're doing that like just spin as many
plates as possible do all the [ __ ] you
dream about like if somebody is doing
something that interests you try it even
if like you know you've never done it
before especially considering I'd never
made a film before we did we just got
lucky lucky timing at work down [ __ ]
so when podcasting came along I was
actually better suited for that like to
just sit around and talk so I was like
oh my god this is like a commentary
track on a laserdisc but there's no
movie let's do this this is fantastic so
I found myself through podcasting and
and really got to put the voice out
there like you know the evening with
Kevin Smith specials were one way to
kind of be like hi this is Who I am
beyond the work but the podcasts allowed
me to like go deep and and also like
share my friends that was the bigger
thing yeah like I got to put a shine a
light on people that I thought were
impressive like you know you've heard
from me for years now hear from [ __ ]
Jason Mewes himself not the character
Jay but him or Scott Mosier or Ralph
Garman and Mark Barnard and Andy
McCullough feels like being able to
highlight people who I'm like
I think these people are smart and funny
right that was part of what I loved
about podcasting you know and you know
you got to remember part of it too came
from at that point I was doing a lot of
q and A's by myself and that's how you
do Q&A they go up there and just answer
questions so I do that all over the
country always by myself and there was a
part of me that was like not lonely but
I'm like man I wish I had like you know
I wish I was The Smothers Brothers like
I wish I had there was someone else I'm
always looking for like a best friend or
a partner in crime and so suddenly the
idea of doing podcasts we're like oh I
can go onstage with somebody and have a
conversation like this could be fun too
so that allows you to show even more of
who you are you know and if you listen
to the podcast it's like weird you get a
bunch of different versions of me
SModcast is probably where you get the
most authentic version they're all
unfiltered Jay and Bob get old I'm kind
of his guide I'm the guy keeping it on
Rails and stuff but that's definitely
more about Jason Hollywood babble-on I
play the idiot second banana right with
Terrell so like I instantly go into the
the kind of submissive role shows do you
have now
Fatman beyond with mark barnard and that
one is like that that's actually pretty
close to real Kevin Smith too because
that's just me Fanning out on things I
like that podcast because it's like same
reason I like Hollywood babble-on I get
to talk about anything but me and so
that's still even though you're not
talking about you reveals a lot about
who you are like because of the fat man
fat man I'm Batman which became fat man
beyond podcast like I got I was able to
embrace how [ __ ] you know weepy and
emotional I am like you know cuz now I
just you know I am a guy so you're
expected to be stoic and [ __ ] or at
least I was and then I started like just
crying over comic books and come up with
movies and like putting that out there
in the world you'd hear me on the
podcast and [ __ ] and sometimes I like
shot myself watching flash and crying
which led to me getting a job on flash
as well so like I learned to wear my
emotions on my sleep because the
audience was okay with that
like anytime I push the edge a little
bit outside the movies in a podcast and
let him know a little bit more about who
I was they didn't judge me they weren't
shitty like the [ __ ] cry were flash
and [ __ ] tune in Alyssa this [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever [ __ ] but people being
like I know how you feel man that [ __ ]
makes me [ __ ] emotional too and
suddenly you get to be you even more
publicly so I I'm with you I I of all
the Kevin Smith's I like Kevin Smith the
best like the the one that's like oh
that's who he is yeah it's cool and I
think it's allowed you you mean being
somebody who was just there from the
very beginning you were at the vanguard
like the forefront of developing your
own audience like at what point did you
realize like hey I don't have to you
know make huge movies that appeal to
everybody like I've got these people
they love me I'm gonna take care of them
and like I'm good it never occurred to
me to make huge movies it also never do
to me that I didn't have to be you had
that cop-out experience yeah there's
that who heavens and that were these
broadcasts where you talked about that
leading up to it and did it sound like a
car wreck slowly evolving Carla you know
there was definitely tension between you
and Bruce Willis I mean that's all I
remember vaguely it wasn't their
original name for that movie like a
couple of great and the only only movie
you did that you didn't write yeah of
all the flicks I've done yeah that was
the only one I didn't write and it was I
mean now I do that with Supergirl and
flash episodes but that was like you
know oh my gosh I've never done it for
I'd done it once prior to cop-out I
directed a pilot for a TV show called
Reaper mm-hmm but I wound up doing so
much like say this say this that that
felt more like me cop-out was definitely
like somebody else's script me go let me
see if I could Steven Soderbergh this
[ __ ] and directions right you know I
didn't depends of yeah some people like
moving [ __ ] blows and some people
like unlike it honestly we were always
trying to make like a TNT a movie that
could play on TNT and TBS over and over
again like the TNT classics at the time
we were making the movie I remember
we're like hopefully one day this would
be a TNT classic and now it does play on
TV so I feel kind of like I ain't well
it's where it needs to be but this idea
of like developing your own
just be that happen accidentally love
you I mean that's like what the internet
is all about now and it didn't stop her
own
the first filmmaker I would say Ed Burns
did the same thing he's done a great job
of like just making movies that he likes
to make on micro-budget it's yeah they
don't have to be huge deals but he's got
his audience yeah I love him and you've
got the same thing
I'm very mine was accidental mine was I
just wanted to talk to anybody who had
an interest in this [ __ ] like you
know I I couldn't believe anyone gave a
[ __ ] about clerks and so when they did
it was easy to engage with them like hi
I can answer anything you want about
this [ __ ] thing like I spent my year
of my life doing this biggest thing I've
ever did in my life so it was the
expectation when you're on set doing
clerks none zero
there's my hope my hope was I read an
article as an article has an a-frame
right beyond that door that in the
Village Voice about Richard Linklater
when he took slacker to the IFF M so I
was like all right we gotta make a movie
and bring it to this IFF em that was my
only goal so the whole time we were
Meghan and I even like I went to visit
the I FM that year before and just to
see what it was like I'd never been to a
film festival in my life this is not
technically a Film Festival it's it's a
film market blast more than anything
else so I looked in at it I heard about
it through that article and and that ami
table and wrote about Richard Linklater
and then there was also this like TV
special that had aired on CBS called
made in New York and Ron silver hosted
it and it just looked at like some
movies that were being shot on the
streets of New York and then it looked
at indie films that were like if it was
like I'm going and now you know there's
a whole new wave of filmmakers who make
these little movies and this must have
happened in 1991 I saw it on TV like how
HAARP the how Hartley's how hardly Jim
Jarmusch Spike Lee but they were talking
specifically about the i FM marketplace
like look at all these kids make movies
and they try to sell their hustle on
their movies at the marketplace so I had
a visual for what it looked like then I
went up one day to look at it myself and
I was like ah right this is what we're
going for we make this movie and then we
take it to this IFF
and then people see it and like in the
case of slacker Sony Pictures classic
borderline hopefully someone will buy it
like I I wasn't educated enough to know
that like that's not what really happens
at the marketplace I was confusing it
with like a Film Festival and to be fair
that at that point didn't even happen in
film festivals the year we went to
Sundance was the first year that any
film had been bought at the film
festival generally speaking they were
bought prior to the film festival or
after the film festival ended but that
whole like heated the moment like we got
to buy this that happened our year we
weren't the first the first movie to be
bought at Sundance was go fish also
represented by John Pearson the guy who
represented our film also a black and
white movie ours was the boys black in
my movie there's the girls black my
movie is about lesbians so that movie
sold first we sold after like four days
later John Pearson sold our movie to
Miramax
they sold I think to Goldwyn Samuel
Goldwyn coming so we had no expectations
of like we'll go to Sundance in this
movie we'll sell I just thought we have
to go to the IFF em the independent
feature film market because that's what
Richard did and someone will see it and
then the journey begins like that
article in The Village Voice was like
road maps treasure map I was like we
just have to follow this but even taking
a step back to see slacker it was
impactful right made me wanna be a film
yeah you see that movie there's no other
movie like it there hasn't been any
movie like it's since absolutely agreed
and and that's not to say like you know
oh my god it'll blow you away some
people see in there like this is the
movie that made you want to be a
filmmaker like and yes because number
one it was smart
number two it looked doable like that's
the thing it was smart and doable like
it was clever I was engaged with it I
was like this guy's smart he just made a
movie in his hometown and it's not even
like the main character there's no main
character just follow one person to
another to another and you're looking a
life day in life of this community as
smart and then the second thing was like
my god this is doable
like this don't look expensive at all
like you know we had no internet so I
couldn't go online and be like how much
did it cost but I read in an interview
later on that it was not very expensive
at all and I was like
it's like that's what got me into indie
film you could make one of these movies
inexpensively like if you got a really
great location you know I'd heard Robert
Rodriguez interviewed on the Howard
Stern Show and he said you know she went
feral mariachi he goes I had a guitar
case a bus and a turtle and I wrote them
all into the movie so he's like right
what you got he's like some people
first-time filmmakers right the movie in
space they don't have space he's going
but I wrote what I had access to and as
listening to that interview and I was
sitting in Quickstop convenience store
where I was working and I looked around
and I was like what do I have access to
what could I write a movie about what do
I have that's different and I looked at
the store and I was like you know I've
never seen anybody make a
convenience-store movie I see movies
that ended in convenience stores like
[ __ ] Fast Times at Ridgemont High ends
in a convenience store but I've never
seen a movie set in a convenience store
like me that's what I got going for me
and it turns out that's what it was man
it was the great equalizer
you know people whether you lived in a
community store like I did as employee
whether you interacted with the
convenience store regularly like you
know people who lived in town went there
every day for milk and [ __ ] and
cigarettes or weather every once in a
while you just [ __ ] walked into a
good minister everyone has a working
fundamental knowledge of a community or
worldwide
and I never put that together I was
never like strategic about it all I did
was look around and be like well this
place like I got a set this is a set
like you know if you're gonna make a
movie do it someplace interesting all
the shelves are full I don't have to
build this like the toppers will let me
do it here because I'm here all the time
anyway and they're never here so I'll
just ask him kinda shoot a movie here
and I did and they said go ahead all
seem doable based on seeing slacker
right yeah and then it blows up through
slacker clerks clerks we yeah we got
very lucky I mean but to hear for those
that are like you know all the blow up
part that'll never happen to me let me
just make clear clerks never played on
more than 50 screens in its entire
theatrical life it was a true art house
release and stuff so it wasn't like you
know we were on a [ __ ] thousand
screens and [ __ ] it was never fifty at
once it was like 50 max and prints got
shuffled around from place to place and
50 was his why
it ever went generally played on like
played in all the big cities that was it
but the story around it was big that
[ __ ] traveled that traveled and
captured people's imaginations like poor
people like hey this kid he he worked in
this commune story made a movie there
and I never imagined that that would
connect like for my money Robert
Rodriguez had the be-all-end-all [ __ ]
back story I donated my body to medical
science to make a seven thousand dollar
movie so I didn't think like us going
like we made a movie set in a
convenience store for twenty seven
thousand five hundred seventy-five
dollars would be news at all I thought
people be like why'd you waste so much
money this guy [ __ ] did it for 7 grand
where'd your other 20 go on Coke and
hores so I never thought that anyone
would be like ooh the back story is
interesting but we were up at Sundance
and by the second [ __ ] screening
that's what the media start writing
about people in print were like this is
adorable
this guy he works at this store in New
Jersey he made this movie about shooting
in a convenience store while working at
that store he brought up here to
Sundance and then when he goes home he's
going back to work at that convenience
store like can you believe it and then
you know they were like hey do you want
to talk and I love to talk so I was like
oh yeah absolutely and because I've been
a fan of stand-up comedy my life and
anytime I saw someone with a microphone
in their hand they were trying to be
entertaining I didn't go the route of
erudition I wasn't there to teach people
how to be a filmmaker I barely knew how
to do it myself as people could see from
clerks I decided to try to be funny like
you know look people are looking at you
you got a mic in your hand and asking
you questions about your movie you can't
answer it like a true filmmaker being
you've only done it once so tell them
funny stories about how you got to get
the cat to [ __ ] on cue or you know how
you got the film for real cheap and [ __ ]
like that
make it entertaining that would be
extending the movie so the movie ends
and people have a good time and instead
of standing up there dryly being like
you know well the art of film is to
capture a human truth I just sat up
there bill let me tell you the story
about how we got the cat to [ __ ] on cue
so they're like as relatable as the
movie is the guy who made the movie was
talking about afterwards he's pretty
relatable to man and slowly over the
course of like you know foot five six
years after of doing Q&A is after movies
you get comfortable yeah
up there and suddenly I realize oh I
have another usable skill I can just go
up and talk about the movies like it's
fun to make the movies and stuff but now
I can go up and talk about the movies
and that could be its own unique thing
what do you think about the kind of
explosion of podcasting in the last I
mean even in the last like a year or two
where now everybody's got a podcast and
it's blown up somebody was there funny a
one-man look I'm happy for it I've been
out there for years telling people like
record a podcast like I would end most
of my shows with like everybody should
be recording a podcast at this point
because you never know it could turn
into something bla bla bla I'm all for
it I'm all for the democratization of
conversation like let everybody have a
chance at bat let everybody step up to
the mic let everybody have their own
[ __ ] show we all know how to do it
we've all listened to media watched
media our entire lives and when you do
that you're always like man if I was in
charge I'd do it differently well here's
your [ __ ] check right I've handled
fair entry
none whatsoever nobody could tell you
know there's no like gatekeeper who's
like well your art is not good enough
hence you're not going to be a part of
this you sit down the microphone and
maybe there's somebody interesting or
you lose your phone and now they have
apps where you can literally publish
from your phone smart very smart but
yeah it's crazy how easy it is now and
and I'm all for it I think everybody
should have a show you now with that
many people doing shows everybody can't
expect to have an audience that's the
only problem like when we started we
started in February 2007 it was easy to
find an audience because there's plenty
of audience and not a lot of shows right
now shows get created all the [ __ ]
time like when we started all the shows
that I've started like you know we used
to take pictures of the charts and [ __ ]
like that on iTunes like the screen shot
yes like launching at number one I'd be
like oh my god like even my friend
Malcolm Ingram had a podcast called
blowhard and when we not have when we
launched that that we launched that it
[ __ ] number one like it was so easy
back in the day now I doubt I could
launch a podcast at number one it beat
hard it's a crowded marketplace and now
the the dominant podcast seems to be the
political podcast political podcast and
true-crime Oh
likely the love-juice on highly produced
storytelling which to me is like I mean
that's fine you want distributed through
podcast by all means do whatever you
want but that that's like you know with
those dog casts are like NPR level great
coming from NPR talent in some cases
like trained professional uh I ain't
taking anything away from anybody all
are welcome oh yeah I'm like a lady in
poltergeist rush over children all are
welcome that being said you know I think
of podcasting as kind of like ham radio
like a bunch of enthusiasts who are like
oh I could never get play in that
community again nobody's ever gonna hire
me for the radio or to give me a TV show
so this is mine I get to do it here so
when you know folks who can get jobs
like jump into it folks like me you know
as a filmmaker and I could stand on
stage and talk but I love the idea of
the medium like what I get to have my
own show [ __ ] it I'm gonna do it you
know it's just I it's it's a heads odd
big fish swamp in the pond jumping in
and going like oh [ __ ] like I just saw
Conan O'Brien is down and started one
where you're like uh Paul hey [ __ ]
boy your fingers on the pulse buddy but
but that being said it's like here comes
another one a big fish can jump in the
pool this place a lot of water get a lot
of guests and [ __ ] like that and you
know I'm not good for him but you know
he figured out a little light but he
figured out what I figured out which is
like you can pivot to this this is
something else to do that's why I jumped
into it and control it and own it and
there's nobody there 20 controls and
owns his own show but who knows for how
much longer and maybe that's why the
podcasting things yeah yeah but I but I
don't begrudge anybody why they do it
man
it's just when big names get into it you
know it's kind of like here I'll liken
it to and again I'm not condemning
anybody because I was a quasi big-name
when I got into it it's like indie film
movement remember when the indie film
movement started it was cats who've
never done it before or like I'm gonna
pick up a camera and I'm gonna try this
and they have no access but like [ __ ]
they got passion and talent and spirit
and stuff like that
and then all sudden everybody wines make
an indie movie you know like [ __ ]
DreamWorks made an indie movie with
American Beauty and wins a [ __ ] Oscar
and stuff like that and all these big
names like Miramax they're responsible
like for putting huge [ __ ] faces and
indie films and yet Miramax is
responsible for my career as well by
buying clerks they put me on the [ __ ]
map but suddenly the indie field is
diluted by famous people people that can
go get jobs and real studio movies are
working for real Studios like I'm a slum
it make an indie movie instead and
that's my small are welcome but at the
same time bring break yeah and also it's
just like what started as like hey man
now the little people can make something
gets taken over by the big people
because if you're an investor do you
want to invest in some [ __ ] shitty
movie about a guy works in a convenience
store or do you want to invest in Emma
you know a retelling of the classic
story with a movie star a couple [ __ ]
movie stars and it's gonna shoot over in
England and stuff we're ameliorate your
cost cuz it'll run on BBC over there and
over here you're just putting out in
theaters and so you know it's like
suddenly a businessperson is like well
that way it makes a lot more sense we
can make a lot more money and so the
average person you know who didn't
really have access the outsider if you
will suddenly kind of got squeezed to
the to the far ends you know until they
get tired and create a movement and
mumblecore you know like [ __ ]
suddenly mumble trying to take back like
a new you know where's the next place
we're podcasting is that moment right
now though it's like there's so many
[ __ ] people doing it it's way crowded
and it's only gonna get more crowded
because now people are waking up to like
oh wait I can do this my house and hey
you're a name people know who you are so
like don't don't stop and listen to your
podcast cuz I've seen you on TV or
something like that
so everyone jumps in and again I and
against that the more at the merrier but
that's I've now seen firsthand two
industries change like since the moment
I got into them and the first one I get
into let's be fair that industry been
around for a long time but the
podcasting was interesting because I
always felt like wow we're here for
something new we're watching someone get
built and then slowly as it went on I
would have these moments of dawning
realization of like battlestar go
this is all happening before it will all
happen again like when we got an
advertiser the only reason we got an
advertiser on our podcast was because I
was like hey podcasting is free it don't
cost nothing and one day my accountant
was it cost you I was like what do you
mean it's like more people listen this
[ __ ] podcast of yours the more we
have to pay server cause you're eating
like bandwidth yeah I was like what do
you mean I didn't know this [ __ ] and
she's like you're eating a bandwidth
it's costing money and stuff so there's
no such thing as a free podcast free to
others not to you and I was like [ __ ]
well I don't want to pay for this [ __ ]
like I enjoyed doing it but like how
much is this cost and she told me I was
like jesus [ __ ] christ
so I was like we gotta get it we got to
do something and so I didn't say
SoundCloud if none of this existed like
and it wasn't me it was my my own
personal server so I wasn't like let's
let's create a commercial like cuz that
didn't happen nowadays you'd be like
let's get advertisers but like there was
nothing like that
so I said to Scott Mosier I was like
this is the primitive language I was
like you know we need to get something
like a corporate sponsor remember you
know that movie that Robert Redford did
the gameshow movie and quiz show he said
yeah I was like remember how in quiz
show 21 was sponsored by Geritol he was
like yeah it's like that's what we need
like a Geritol like somebody who
sponsored the whole [ __ ] thing and
they could put their name on and there
in exchange for us having their name in
the podcast they're getting like our
listeners and like and I was explaining
it like this had never been done before
and really Scott goes what do you mean
like commercials and I was like yeah I
guess what we need are but it was kind
of a quote-unquote like branded
entertainment yeah that's what they
would call it now for me it was because
of Zach you marry makeup or know we had
a reference in the movie to the
fleshlight right and somebody had sent
us a letter saying hey man I heard the
reference in the movie and we
appreciated it and if you ever want to
make a fleshlight with us we'd love to
do it sign the people of fleshlight
uh-huh so you know is one of those
things I filed in the drawer like what a
funny letter like to get a letter from
the fleshlight people how cool then when
we were doing this thing where I was
like I got to find a [ __ ] person to
pay for this podcast first person I
thought of was the fleshlight I was like
they said they wanted to do something
with us so I was like should we reach
out to flashlights cuts like well it's
not like you can
reach out to Pampers and Wonder Bread so
you might as well reach out to
fleshlight and so we did we were like we
want to we want to do like these
cartoons can you sponsor them and put
your name on the show and stuff and so
that was how we and what will sell they
the first organization to ever sponsor a
podcast they were definitely the first
organization of sponsors marques I'm
sure Leo Laporte on this week in tech
had to have somebody doing something but
I would say we were the first ones to
look outside the box and go like what is
our audience familiar I would have never
heard of the fleshlight had it not been
for podcast that was that was also how I
got tight with Joe Rogan because Joey
shots meetings like this fleshlight for
real he's gone I got a podcast should I
should I use these fleshlight people try
this the guy behind he is the dude from
Austin I think his name was Bob yeah
he's gone on to start on it yes light
was his family business yes yeah we met
that dude and he kind of walked us
through it and [ __ ] like that it was a
but those were the Wonder Years it was
like you know like the way people go to
Sundance now and like there's all these
corporate you know [ __ ] stops where
you can get a free pair of jeans and
[ __ ] if you take pictures and blah blah
blah like the you know now podcasting is
the same way like you said there's an
app specifically for recording a podcast
that will help you upload it and [ __ ]
like that you could buy a podcasting kit
you know there's a an entire economy now
that's based on ear balls you know
something that we didn't know that term
bet well back when we began but like
that's that's the name of the game when
you're podcasting and stuff so now there
are a lot of podcasts that exist and
again I'm crashing on my board [ __ ]
on them them all for as many as possible
but a lot of them entered the space for
profit where they're like well is a
business and we never did we entered the
space for the glory of like somebody's
gonna give I can record my own radio
show like [ __ ] oh my god that's worth my
time and effort and [ __ ] and we never
thought about monetizing it until
somebody was like hey this cost you
money I'm like oh [ __ ] I can't let that
happen I gotta cover my cost so I do I
don't have regret about it but I wish
that and I don't even know if I wish it
would have been nice if it if I never
turned this into a business for myself
right that it was still just the hobby
it was and I still never done it like
ever needed yeah it never needed to be a
business for you know but you know but
that's how a business person thinks yeah
you're like my goal in life was like
figure out what you love to do and then
figure out it get paid for it and the
danger of that is that everything you
love becomes your job you run out of
hobbies because all of a sudden you you
like something you're like now how do I
[ __ ] how do we do this for a living
and I'm lucky I'm breathing rare
rarefied air if I could figure out a way
to sit down with a buddy and have a
conversation we were gonna have for free
get paid for it and that's my job then I
feel very funny that's that's fantastic
but it's also hard not to be romantic
about the pure you know sort of origins
just doing it for the sake of [ __ ]
doing it of like because by God we can
because somebody created this weird
technology where we can just sit here
and talk to each other and there'll be
an audience for it online so that's how
the audience was never the intention
like you know I could not be honest
about that from the jump
even in making clerks I was never like I
must think of the audience I think every
real artist or I'm not saying I'm more
real than others I think every artist is
working for themselves
it's masturbatory you're trying to do
your thing tell your story I want to
show you what's in my head and heart and
stuff like that so you have to serve
yourself first and I think we're all
built to think that way for me the
audience always came second and I treat
the audience insanely well I mean as
you've seen they've been around me for
nearly 20 25 years of my career dudes
this January 25 years since clerks I
built an audience and they've lot of
them have stuck with me and new ones
come all the time and stuff so clearly I
love the audience I include them in
everything they're a huge part of what I
do but I had to be honest with myself
over the course of my career I'm like
let's be honest you're the most selfish
person I've ever met most something made
me not selfish you're the most
self-involved human being I've ever met
in my life this is all about you this is
all about getting your ideas out there
telling your [ __ ] story and [ __ ] if
you were a child you'd be sitting there
gone my toys like I'm telling the story
you can have these these are the ones
I'm playing with so if that's the case
just just embrace that yeah embrace yes
depart allows you have to have a self
belief that you
point of view I'm at about to say it's
about so frustrated it's so question
because periodically like I spend most
of my life going like well I you know I
just saw spider-verse into the
spider-verse
well they must know what I think and you
know and I don't I don't tell them about
negative money navigate the world until
they hear your take on this movie and
it's only fed by the people in my social
media who are like I ain't seen this
until you talk about it I've been
waiting to see you talk about oh thank
God you finally said something I've been
waiting to find out and suddenly go like
they aren't waiting they do need to know
what I hear it's it's and again this is
a story that we all tell each other
right there's some hearty - pod story
that like Kevin Smith's opinion on this
[ __ ] matters one day it's gonna fall
apart but right now I'm enjoying it and
the heart attack didn't reset that no it
made it stronger like the heart attack
made people go like we almost lost him
this year what does he think about
spider-man now it's almost it is a it is
a superhero archetype because here you
are the Phoenix raising from the ashes I
mean utility basically like
live-streamed this whole thing I mean I
put up the Facebook live I was like I'm
alive here's what happened right yeah
it's been interesting being me and and
part of it was definitely planned and
it's been she's like I want to make this
movie clerks but everything that came
after that has been gravy and figuring
it out as you go along like I didn't
realize that my career would be me until
like suddenly one day I was like oh I
could just go out and talk about making
the movie yes you are the art project
that's and that's I think what every
artist really dreams about and doing
ultimately and stuff you present your
art as a statement of who you are but
really ultimately
it's a it's once removed from you if you
could be the art project I'm not talking
about in a lady Gaga where a meet kind
of way but if that works for you go
ahead but in a performative way like
when you see like when Banksy when that
auction happened and they shred it you
know banks right at the painting like
he's he is the art instillation Banksy
though humble enough to you never see
him right you don't even know where he
is that's part of the provide stick is
like hi I'm right oh my god you can't
stop me I'm stalking you guys because I
don't want to go
I've been I've been to the party and the
party's wonderful the party is we're
gonna pay you to make pretend and say
the things didn't run your heart and
mind I don't want to leave that party
until I die until I leave this world
physically and stuff because I don't
want to go back getting a real job like
I had real jobs they saw compared to
this so I don't want a real job again I
just want to stay in the show right till
the end and unlike other people who you
know as children dream about doing
something and grow up and get to do it
like your average athlete average
athlete age is out of this [ __ ] they
have to give up their [ __ ] childhood
dream at one point they get to do it for
a while but they got to hang up those
shoes or their skates or whatever the
[ __ ] sooner or later because their body
won't let him physically do it my line
of profession my line of work you know I
could conceivably even from like an iron
lung be Kevin Smith you know I could
still like Facebook live and have guests
how do you maintain fidelity to that
when you're on the receiving end I
imagine of a lot of people saying you
should do this why aren't you doing this
you're doing this wrong you should if
you really want the career you know you
got to do this movie they gave up like
the beautiful thing is if you have yes
if you outlast them they're like this is
the guy that made tusk obviously he's
not listening that's it once you get to
Tuscan yoga Rose is there like we're
never getting through [ __ ] he's lost
let's pay attention to somebody else and
and that's fine like I get it there's
always gonna be like a you know armchair
director telling you how to live your
life and I also and I'm not saying that
in a shitty way I get why people in at
home the home viewer why some of them
like get turned off to me because in
some ways I'm a bit of an avatar for
them like he's like me he just watched
all this [ __ ] he knows all this [ __ ] the
only difference is he tried to make
something and it worked out luck and
timing [ __ ] he got his foot in the
[ __ ] door so some people go like
alright he's us now this is what I would
do with my career and then periodically
you don't do it or in my case all the
time you don't do with your career what
they would do with the career and so
some people get mad at you like you
wasted your opportunity my [ __ ] you've
got all that and all you did was [ __ ]
tusk
[ __ ] you and they drop out or Jersey
girl I lost a lot of people on Jersey
girl and [ __ ] because it's something
like that
so I like I get it because because if
you're investing in the kid from nowhere
thing you know you're investing and some
people are like I invested you know same
way they get you know heated about like
an athlete that [ __ ] up during the game
like hey man what the [ __ ] there's a
sense of ownership like I took you under
my wing you're my boy I went out there
in the world and said you're the [ __ ]
guy and you're gonna drop the ball like
that they get mad at you and [ __ ] like
that
so over the years I've learned to have a
relationship with it in the beginning
you know you got to remember I was there
for the advent of the Internet I was
there for the first time where people
would jump online a total [ __ ]
stranger and tell you to drop dead and
that your work is terrible
like now that's commonplace now we all
know how to deal with that but that was
at a time when I'm like what
ruah dude we call the police this person
like told me to die like do they really
mean it and [ __ ] like that so you grow a
layer you know of skin thicker skin but
also you just learn what it is you learn
to take it all in stride you can't
believe the people that say like you're
a genius and you can't believe the
people who say you're an idiot
uh-huh you just do you and then slowly
people just stop telling you what to do
there will always be somebody you know
what you should do and that's fine like
we're all entitled to that but like the
people who seem most frustrated about
like you know why the [ __ ] isn't he
doing that seem to it maybe they're just
given up maybe they're like he's not a
serious filmmaker and they've moved on
and that's that's fine with less
scrutiny I might function a little bit
better yeah well the positive flip side
of that and what I think is your
greatest gift is you you allow a certain
set of marginalized people to feel okay
about loving what they love yes as you
love it so much as long as it's comics
and pop culture and not Nazism no like
sort of nerd culture whatever I mean now
nerd culture is pop culture and it's the
dominant go right but still just having
you know this this level just being so
steeped in some of these things that
tend to isolate you know certain kind of
kid right there to provide community and
say hey man it's cool like I like this
stuff
- in fact and I know everything about it
now let me sit down and tell you about
it right it's okay to love that kind of
[ __ ] there was a period where like when
I was a kid you know you like comics you
were stupid but if you like sports you
were [ __ ] real and it's like what
like they're both [ __ ] made-up like
not none of them are real like yet
people are running around on a field and
[ __ ] but that's a game like nothing's
gonna come of this except somebody's
gonna arbitrarily decide who the [ __ ]
winner is it's not gonna cure cancer
it's not gonna move society forward it's
just [ __ ] fun so is my [ __ ] my shits
fun and guess what my shits just like
your [ __ ] was your [ __ ] people get up on
a field wear masks and colorful costumes
and fight each other guess what we do it
my [ __ ]
people would want masks we're called for
custom color for costumes and they fight
each other like it's no [ __ ]
different it's true we made a decision
somewhere along the line that one was
socially approved of and this end this
is for kids like this one you this is
for kids because games are for children
but for some reason this game you could
follow into your adulthood and that's
mature there's maturity to with liking
sports even though it's a [ __ ] game
and for some reason when I was a kid
there was an immaturity if you carried
comic books into adulthood but now that
that line is erased like let's be honest
we now live in a culture where pop
culture and comic books and genre
dominates or at least stands shoulder to
shoulder with sports but I might go one
step further and say it's the dominant
culture now where kids want to [ __ ]
now go to the movies and [ __ ] play
video games and read comic well maybe
not read comics but they should and
watch TV and stuff like that and engage
with other fans of the like-minded
individuals of the same kind of stuff
then then the other people then the
people who'd do it in sports I mean look
I mean this is probably gonna be an
unfair statistic but our cable cord
cutters
you know ESPN audience is shrinking we
see that every day within the disney
kind of stock results and what now and
they're always kind of reporting it's
like we've lost more people and i'm not
saying they're all coming over comics
but you only hear that [ __ ] about jobs
you don't hear Marvel going like we
can't make any money with these comic
book movies like they just keep making
more
and more because sports are fun story
don't get me wrong and the audience is
responsible for applying more story to a
sporting event like different yeah you
know what's gonna happen you don't it's
happening but there is no story there
it's literally like flip a coin and it's
like you know you're moving a ball up a
field and [ __ ] like that but we assign
great sports writers assign stories like
that this is a kid hardscrabble kid came
out of nowhere and learn how to handle a
puck by himself that's all the [ __ ] that
you add only difference between sports
love and sports and love and comic books
and movies and [ __ ] is they give you
they spoon feed you the story in comics
you know they don't have to sit there
and imagine poet must be hard I wonder
how long that person had to train to be
good with a bowling ball and [ __ ]
they'll show you in the movie like his
mother died at the hands of a villain
and that's why he got good with a
bowling ball that's gripping story so I
could see where people are leaning more
towards movies and comic book
entertainment then then sports if I'm
correct and I'm sure somebody out there
is like you're wrong Kevin you're wrong
it's our number one export which
entertainment or sports entertainment
yeah I guess Sports is on that list too
I would imagine
well culture you know the culture that
we export but I think that that scale
has tipped I mean we're in a comic-con
culture oh no question I love it I got
lucky like thank God cuz we were in
sports culture I'd be [ __ ] my career
would be over oh my god I'd be done but
since I got hockey I could talk hockey
that's it yeah but since like good news
isn't for me at least is in 1995 when I
made Mallrats
we made this movie where we were like
you know we presupposed a world where
everybody knew who Stan Lee was and that
wasn't the case when we made the movie
but the world grew up to be that horse
and everyone did eventually know who
Stan Lee was so I was just in a good
place because people like you but to
talk about this [ __ ] for 20 years what
are your thoughts and they stick a
microphone in your mouth and I'm happy
to give my opinion at any given time
yeah and generally my opinion is
positive when I was kid I'd [ __ ] on
things as an adult I don't really do
that I'm really [ __ ] on anything and
[ __ ] over a decade cuz and there are
things I don't like trust me but you'll
never hear about it because why would I
waste my breath telling you oh I love to
keep it positive I love seeing the
effect that has on people like I love
when people compliment me on that like
[ __ ] somebody going like oh I love the
movies I love how they like man I love
that you're so positive like it really
[ __ ] brings me up that's what means
something at the end
day like you know eventually people are
gonna stop talking about these movies I
won't because they're my movies and
stuff but like eventually people are
like oh yeah clerks I think I saw that
like decades ago but so many more
important things have happened since
then see can't always affect him with
your work and let's be honest I lose
some people with my work lately like
they don't give a [ __ ] about the walrus
movie and [ __ ] like that but where you
can still grab people right by the seat
of their pants or in their face or
especially in their [ __ ] heart is by
showing them something they never really
see which is positivity it's a negative
[ __ ] world I love the Internet oh my
god it's built for [ __ ] negativity
because there's nothing but anonymity
there you can hide beyond a shield and
[ __ ] all over the [ __ ] world I can't
do that I'm not anonymous people know
who I am so I'm not gonna stand there
and [ __ ] [ __ ] on the world
everybody's doing this two paths in this
life right it's creation and destruction
and the destruction path is [ __ ]
crowded because that's an easy lane to
travel on man oh my god
anybody can [ __ ] [ __ ] on something
else and say it's bad I try to go to the
creation lane wide open lots of free
mobility and [ __ ] cuz people don't want
to try that it's risky you got to put
something yourself out there and people
might judge you for it and [ __ ] like
that so I've taken it upon myself
conscious effort over the last 10 15
years to be the positive guy to just be
like look just kill them with kindness
because it's just as real you know what
I'm saying like kindness and being
positive it's just as real as negative
negativity and being shitty it's a story
that should tell yourself so if you're
gonna make up a [ __ ] story anyway why
not let it be a positive story why not
let it be a story where [ __ ] works out
for everybody so when I talk to people
about their dreams and Leah I talked to
a lot of people like I want to make
films I'm like oh my god you will you're
gonna do it because I did it and I'm a
chimp and I know how lazy I am and it
worked out for me but I could see the
[ __ ] passion in you these are the
things that help me let me tell you I'll
pass them on maybe that'll [ __ ] help
you and [ __ ] feed that beast feed any
creative urge so long as that creative
urge isn't like I want to creatively
kill people how about I bury people up
to their necks and run over their heads
with lawn mowers discourage that sort of
thing
discourage any creativity that involves
hurting others creativity though when
people like I want to do I want to make
[ __ ] right therefore man I can't give
him the money some cats come at you like
well they give you the money to do it
but I'm like hey you're talking to the
guy who didn't have money given to him
either so I know where I've I speak
trust me it's gonna mean more
if you do it on your own and more
importantly there's no [ __ ] help
coming I'll be honest with you no one's
coming to help you make your dreams come
true that's up to right it's like that
speech that mark Duplass gave at South
by Southwest what'd he say he gave this
keynote where he was like the cavalry is
not common man you're like what is it
was he got up it I think it was a year
or two ago at South by Southwest and he
basically was like I might have an email
by a decade I got up at Sundance for
red-state and said the same thing I was
like it's on you I didn't take your
relatability and your optimism and your
positivity and your encouragement and
being this like you know example of like
DIY success is empowering to people and
so it's almost a responsibility for you
to shoulder that and can as we all know
with my power it was great billy's I
look around your museum it's amazing
it's as you look around it's just my
face oh but I will say my favorite thing
was the [ __ ] Banzai poster in the
bathroom thank you I had that poster I
loved that that but that movie shaped a
great deal of Who I am today some movies
you know edible movie it's a that's a
fantastic movie but it's a movie that
like nobody knew like it was one of the
first movies yes yes yes I remember
passing and showing it to my dad yes you
have to see you didn't get it at all but
it was like that pride of like finding
something that's that's what social
media is predicated on that same feeling
of like let me share something with you
that's the new currency it's not so much
wealth its information it's being able
to say like I saw spider-verse already
let me [ __ ] tell you what you're in
for or here's a picture of that we did a
video we did of my husband coming home
from the service and we hit him in a
[ __ ] Christmas box and told our son
this is for you and the money unwrapped
the boxes dad [ __ ] popped I saw that
it's beautiful oh my god family
beautiful probably what I saw great yeah
and that counts that's cinema and [ __ ]
like that but passing on that positivity
they remember you for that bro they
don't you know I know it's easy to
remember negative [ __ ] like God believe
me I couldn't I still quote you the
negative review that I got from Kenny
Turan in the LA Times from Mallrats
first sentence was if
Sundance or the AFI ever offers a
curriculum on what not to do as a second
feature Mallrats should be at the heart
of it so I it's easy to remember shitty
things positive things make a deeper
impact positive things can change
person's life sometimes a person just
needs to be told they can do it you can
do it and I'm the person to tell them
because I am that person and when they
look at me saying it they know it's not
bunk they know like look it may or may
not happen but he [ __ ] believes it
and he knows wherever he speaks because
he did it that's why I am believer cuz I
did well I was the DIY guy and it did
work out I'm always very clear about
like look it may not work out like
exactly like it worked out for me but
you're gonna have something at the end
of the day if you bother to go on this
journey and [ __ ] make something
you're gonna have something nobody else
is gonna have that [ __ ] thing
whatever it is that you make and that
thing is priceless like we're all
looking at the end game because we hope
somebody buys whatever it is we're
working on and stuff like that I was
that guy to when I made clerks man I
just wanted somebody to [ __ ] buy this
thing so I could be out of debt [ __ ] but
the making of the thing the having of
the thing I don't own clerks anymore I
don't make any money off of that movie
and I never will for the rest of my life
but I have that movie that's mine I made
that thing and I may not own it
it may be on paper belong to somebody
else but without me that [ __ ] thing
doesn't exist and so it's affected
people in positive way but [ __ ] all that
it's affected me in a profoundly
positive way and as much as there's my
statement I'm gonna leave this world and
a bunch of people I never met are gonna
know a little bit about me based on
seeing my art and it's a lighthouse for
other people it's like this beacon that
says just do it possible yes do it [ __ ]
try it and so when you look back on your
career what are the moments that stick
out like I think people think oh it must
be you know when clerks old or you know
these kind of like highlight you know
had like real things
I mean honestly clerks selling was such
an incredible hi the difference between
we're talking about spot you're like
you're talking about like your favorite
like remember yeah this happened like
what are those things
it's the mundane right it is well from
Mo's like Mo's always remembers fondly
and it's so wild that it
maybe it's because I have the picture
but like he does very vivid memory of us
being at the Cannes Film Festival and we
were part of this section called
International critics week and we didn't
get in because of Miramax
there was a guy who was lobbying for us
for the section and you know Miramax
could care less they had movies with
money in it that they were trying to
take for the festival we kind of got in
last minute through this section
backdoor and Miramax's I go oh good for
you guys and stuff so we went there with
no expectation I mean we were like I
can't believe we're gonna cam with our
first [ __ ] move his nuts but you got
to remember we came off of Sundance that
was even more nuts and the fact that
Miramax bought it that was nuts - so the
whole [ __ ] ride was nuts but we're in
can and the lady you know is taking care
of us for critics week section she's
from Toronto she was like you guys have
to go to this award ceremony for critics
week at the end you know it's tonight
you guys got to go and I'm like I'm any
clothes I didn't bring any dress clothes
and you're supposed to wear dress
clothes because you know what they're
gonna make it exception you have to go
that's a kinda long ago like [ __ ] me
and him just wanting to see movies and
[ __ ] no ceremony should and eat dinner
and finally she's like you have to go
because you're probably going to win an
award and I was like what award
she's like International critics week at
the top award of the section I was like
that's the word that Man Bites Dog won
last year we're never a [ __ ] win that
if anything we want an award for like
being a black and white movie like that
was but we're not gonna win that award
we won that award so we're sitting there
in the audience and they announce it
like the winner and the guys got a thick
German accent cuz it was like
mercedes-benz sponsored it and stuff so
we were half in and barely listening and
stuff we heard our names at one points
they listed the movies and the cloaks I
was like alright and people applauded
and [ __ ] then I'll sudden they go and
Davina is flex and there's a photo of
the moment and it's Mosers back and you
could see my [ __ ] face and so Mosier
was there when it happened but I also
suspect he's seen the photo many times
so it re you know reaffirms the image my
face has just this expression of utter
[ __ ] ah of like are you did we just
win an award at the Cannes Film Festival
with this [ __ ] [ __ ] like you could
still see it in my face emoji talks
about that as Eddie Molokai and you're
in your
everyone's very well dressed and we're
wearing I was wearing a can like
souvenir t-shirt that I bought for 3
bucks under my jacket the moment that
that's promoter that's very moving
moment for for me of course the moment
that like we go to the eating
establishment there was a restaurant at
Park City and that's where we meet
Harvey Weinstein and he buys our movie
but that memory of course is now since
tainted because Harvey's at the center
of it but you can't take it away like
that moment changed my [ __ ] life but
this honestly this is the moment that
I'll take with me to the grave and it
happened before everything else happened
it before anyone saw that movie at
Sundance or anything like that
I was working a quick stop and the movie
said a quick stop so I was literally
just doing Donn text on tazed based on
me so I'm at the register and Bob Hawke
who was a guy who would saw our film at
the IFF M that independent feature film
marketplace I was talking about that I
found through the Richard Linklater
article they meet Albin had written in
the Village Voice so Bob had Sauce
clerks at the IFM he was one of the only
people at our screening who wasn't
casting crew and he had told us you guys
should submit to Sundance we looked at
his badge wearing a badge to identify
him and he didn't have a name on his
badge that made you think like this guy
knows what he's talking about
like it wasn't Miramax or fineline or
something like that it's just that I CI
so uh you know I didn't we didn't think
much of it and then we found out the
next day because we got a bunch of phone
calls important phone calls that this
guy was a big fair and independent film
and he did know where if he spoke and
stuff and he loved clerks fell in love
with he said what a breath of fresh air
and stuff he's telling everybody
those people are getting in touch with
us a meet Albin who wrote that article
that Richard Linklater that I used as a
map she called me the next day and I was
like this can't be a meet Alvin
somebody's playing practical joke and
she was like who would ever pretend to
be me and I was like I'm serious like I
just have I have your article framed
above my desk like that's that's what we
use to make clerks choose like this is
gonna be the best interview I've ever
given so she called Larry Carr - who ran
the new directors for new films program
at the MoMA which is the sister festival
- the New York Film Festival he called
Peter Broderick all bonds do an article
on filemaker magazine i said and none of
them would tell me like who told him
about clark how'd you hear about it
nobody was there how would you have
heard about our movie and finally Peter
Broderick was like there's a man named
Bob Hawke who loves your movie and
everybody loves Bob Bob's been deep in
independent film for years he worked on
the times of Harvey Milk that won an
Oscar and stuff so I got to meet this
man he's the guy that turned it all
around he telling people we met that Bob
Hawke wonderful [ __ ] dude who just
fell in love with clerks like in the
only reason he went he's like I saw the
photo in the catalog and it looked so
pathetic
he said the picture looked so bad like
nobody knew what the [ __ ] they were
doing hey that looks so sad I got to go
watch it and he fell in love with the
movie so Bob Hawke is uh tells us to
submit to Sundance we do and Bob Hawke
calls me at Kwik Stop where I'm working
on that same pay phone that Dante uses
in the movie it calls me up
seven o'clock or something like that he
goes hey Kevin it's Bob walk and say hey
man how's it going and Bob was involved
with the sunday and selection committee
that here like consulting because I just
wanted to tell you that you're in the
top 20 right now he's like of all the
films submitted 450 movies submitted
clerks as one of 20 films that's under
consideration I was like wow man that's
crazy for the dramatic competition there
was only gonna be 14 or 16 14 there's
only gonna be 14 chosen he's gone I
don't know if you're gonna make the
final cut he's gonna buy I thought that
this would make you happy like hearing
that you made it this far you're a
little movie you've never thought of
even submitting to Sundance and stuff
and he's gone it's it's really nice you
should be proud and stuff and I was like
what's gonna keep us out he was like
some people love it some people don't
think it's the sundance worthy film but
right now you are Sundance worthy I was
like thanks man I'm not stuff that's it
man that wasn't the moment half-hour
that's not the moment no way
half-hour later Bob calls up and he goes
it's official it's in stone during the
Sundance Film Festival that changed my
life that that was I'll never forget
that I'll never forget that guy telling
me
and you're on the quick stop phone I was
in the store on the [ __ ] same phone
that Dante's in and the movie and stuff
like that and you know I had no plans
about Sundance my only plans with the
IFF Emin nothing happened to it so like
I was like I'm dead in the water I got
pay this $27,000 back and show like that
like so to suddenly have that guy be
like you're in it just made it all worth
it and like it made me go like thank God
I wasn't stupid like for a while I was
thinking like who do you think you were
why'd you think you could pull this off
why'd you think that you were [ __ ]
special why'd you think this would work
you [ __ ] you know like I was dried
red it'd go I went to film school in
Canada at one point and I dropped out
after four months and went back to work
a quick stop at the convenience store
and I was really dreading that because
you know our community was such that
they all knew I was leaving cuz I was
going film school I'm gonna learn to
make a movie and then suddenly I was
gonna be back in four months
so I dreaded people being like hey
Hollywood what happened Holly what I
thought you were going out to make a
movie Hollywood what happened with the
movie and there was a bit of that when I
came home but I just can't put my nose
to the grindstone like when I got back
from when I dropped out of school I went
to mr. topper mrs. topper rule and
that's tore a quick stop and I said I
want to make a movie here I'm gonna come
back to work here but I want to make a
movie here and they didn't understand
what that meant they thought I'd be
running around the video camera should
though I'll go go yes of course you can
they just wanted me to work there excels
pretty good worker and that meant they
can go stay in Staten Island they didn't
have to come in to store every day but
then so just be that guy who like don't
know why I never I was never proactive
in high school I wasn't the eyes and
sketches in the talent show and I love
being in the plays but like I was not
the planner I was not like [ __ ] I'm
going to college I never applied to
college and [ __ ] like that I didn't have
big plans and big moves and dreams like
oh I wish I could write for Saturday
Night Live but never did anything about
it or anything like that was just hoping
one day to be discovered so for that
call to come and that dude to be like
you're in like you're one of the you're
one of the [ __ ] 14 that are chosen it
meant that I wasn't wrong like maybe
nothing would happen to clerks but hey
[ __ ] it once it's going to the Sundance
Film Festival yeah and you know I
remember when I was watching the movie
the IFF em for the first time I hated it
for the first 10-15 minutes of moving
because there's nobody in the audience
and I'd never seen the movie projected
large on a screen I'd only seen it on
the editing machine so there it is at
the same theater where I saw slacker
like two years prior Oh action Angelica
at the Angelika Film Center so I'm
watching the movie in the first 10 15
minutes of clerks I hate it because I'm
like oh my god it looks like [ __ ] like
it looks like we shot this movie through
a glass of milk
why did why why did I why didn't we
shoot in color and then everyone kept
cursing I was like why is everyone
cursing in this movie everyone keeps
cursing it sounds some [ __ ] harp like
why I think I could do this I'm [ __ ]
I'm like deeply in credit card debt and
like nobody's [ __ ] here all of this
was for [ __ ] nothing like I had a
mini breakdown and then within four
minutes I cog natively reframed it so I
heard some people in the audience
granted they were friends of mine laugh
at the movie and I was like oh alright
how's it going alright I get it
like you know you had no expectation
that this should work out anyway and so
clearly it's not gonna work out so what
you do is paid off just money on a
credit card if you have to get three
jobs you'll get a third job and [ __ ]
like that but make sure you pay it off
and then do this one more time before
you leave this world because she [ __ ]
loved who you were when you were doing
this for the first time in your life you
knew exactly who you were this [ __ ]
that's the thing the commitment to do it
again even if it wasn't gonna work which
was never tested you know what I'm
saying I got full of good ideas but like
had you not gotten who knows what would
have happened like would I have done it
a second time how's it going now yeah
twenty seven thousand exactly no so I
that's my whole career has been like
gravy honestly I had one thing I wanted
to do it's custom I'll make this movie
clerks and it wasn't even I want to make
it and I want these people to pick it up
and I want it to become like a cult
classic or whatever I just want to do
that one [ __ ] thing so everything
after that has been like [ __ ] gravy
lots and lots of gravy even when it's
bad it's still gravy cuz it's like you
know even in the midst of cop out and
[ __ ] Bruce Willis I was like well
this or digging graves in the graveyard
which I did one day
worked for a landscaping company we had
to hand dig a [ __ ] grave actually dug
it great yeah the backhoe went out I
would like getting the hole we got to
dig a grave and digging a [ __ ] grave
going like I don't like this
this is back-breaking labor plus it's
creepy like I got to do something else I
gotta make pretend for a living
so speaking of gravy now it's all vegan
gravy Oh going for two hours the word
vegan hasn't even come up once which is
so weird because it's a big identifying
factor of who I am that's one of the
first things that comes out of my mouth
in every conversation in a restaurant
I'm vegan by the way yeah I had after
the heart attack that I was a
nutritionist at the hospital who was
like you know you might want to think
about a more plant-based diet because
you know all that cholesterol in your
led like that's that's from animal
products and that was a [ __ ] Hulu
Twinkies
and I remember we were too poor to
afford Twinkies so it's a little Little
Debbie Swiss delight so the the
nutritionist said like think about going
plant-based my kids vegan she was in the
rain when she was a gasps do it we have
to augment vegan for a long time three
years ahead of her and I remember
watching her and being like this seems
so hard like all your choices are really
limited like you can't eat it at any
restaurants it's like you know they
ain't got anything and even the stuff
that God is near the food that's not
vegan I was like this poor kid and then
she was there in the room so she was
like do it do it one of us and she was
really profoundly affected by the heart
attack our kids love to let a relatively
first-world existence you know like no
Bad's ever really happened to her and
stuff so she lost her grandfather but
that was years ago she was a kid she was
a baby me having a heart attack was like
the you know [ __ ] welcome to the real
world [ __ ] and so it hit her
hard so she was staying in the hospital
with me that night she stayed overnight
so when the nutritionist was there she
was there as well and her pushing me to
go like you go vegan dad like I was like
you know what like I put this kid
through a scare
I've eaten no way I wanted to eat 47
[ __ ] years let me try eating the way
she wants me for one [ __ ] year I'll
give this a year and see how it goes so
your foot you were that was like a
full-on commitment from the get-go
yeah after the heart attack I was like
alright I'll [ __ ] I'll do it last
piece of meat I ate quasi meat was in
the hospital they like when they gave me
food like the next day one of them like
what
chicken nuggets and I you know it's
crazy that they serve food like that in
the hospital it's just had a hard time
my kid was furious she was just like but
he just saw her tell you're getting food
chicken fried chicken and stuff and I
was like calm down kiddo
but she I took one bite of it and I was
like yeah I don't need that I'm done so
I was the last piece of animal product
and I thought it'd be a lot harder than
it was and I didn't type for those
listening who are like how do I [ __ ]
do it I didn't I didn't do it's not like
I suddenly one day I was like now I'm
gonna eat Brussels sprouts some
asparagus
I still don't eat any of the [ __ ] that I
didn't eat back then slowly I hope it'll
work its way into my diet I became the
vegan where I'm like alright what can I
eat I like beans I seem to like these
chickpeas quite a bit I like this I like
I found things that I could exist on
being a vegan and went that way that
helped cuz of Ray cronies right ray
friend Ray's Ray's diet was what got me
started man and that terrified me
because it went from potatoes to court
well he was fine but it was the the
judge sides like petite like super
hardcore like and that part was a heart
attack dude I'm so happy to eaten the
potatoes was so [ __ ] easy like that's
why I friend of mine Adam Rifkin had
said I know Adam yeah like Penn Jillette
lost 200 pounds bro maybe you should
talk to Penn and so I emailed Penn and
he goes look if you're interested in
doing what I did read my book and then
get back to me so I you know I didn't
read it I listened to his book cause I
love his voice and so I was like I get
it I got it I want to be a cronut and
she was going to do Sugar Ray Ray Ray
alright so I've read the you know that
for those that have never read the book
or unfamiliar with it you know rageous
ass look like you just told Penn put me
put yourself in my hands just trust me
do what I say to do and no matter what
people say just keep doing it it's gonna
seem crazy but [ __ ] everybody else in
fact don't even talk about what you
don't cuz it's too hard to explain it
[ __ ]
so he started Penn on like this potato
diets two weeks all penny it was
potatoes and you know he writes about a
better eloquently in the book and
entertainingly the
what I got I have first and foremost was
like wait a second Penn Jillette lost a
bunch of weight eating [ __ ] potatoes
I love potatoes I give me potatoes
[ __ ] I could try this so I hit him up
as I hit me up with Ray Ray introduced
me to he's like first two weeks yes
gonna be potatoes like please don't call
it a potato famine people do that I hate
it
he's gone but yes that's what it is
you're only gonna be eating potatoes and
I'm part of the Jess side's program like
he could read a thing that he writes
every day and whatnot so for the first
three days I was like oh my god is
amazing now I [ __ ] love potatoes and
I can eat as many as I want I'd sit
there and eat three potatoes and [ __ ]
like that
by the end of the day three you're like
I [ __ ] hate potatoes I hate them so
much you realize you like milk and salt
butter and all the [ __ ] that makes
mashed potatoes good and [ __ ] and left
to your own devices just to eat a potato
which is just baked people listening
like how do you do it
bake them boil them just you can't use
anything though no butter no salt in the
oil and [ __ ] just literally a [ __ ]
potato heat that [ __ ] eat it and you do
that as often as you like yeah what
would you learn very quickly is you
don't want to eat that had a dude on my
podcast
this dude Andrew Taylor he calls himself
spud fit he ate nothing but potatoes for
an entire year
yes I've seen that yeah no he was really
unfit and unhealthy did he do a dry - no
salt no butter no yeah no salt no butter
I think he I think he would have like
there was some kind of like herbs that
heal out of yeah but like nothing that
had any you know sugar fat is like that
smart yeah you went all potatoes for how
long two weeks two weeks the two weeks
and it was I mean what I also learned to
do and you know he teaches it fairly
well in that program as well is fasting
so like I you know I was a guy that was
like I'm hungry having to eat and now
I'm not that person at all now I don't
really I don't eat breakfast I'd find
breakfast to be like hype and propaganda
where's like you got to eat a breakfast
and they don't or I don't I've got a lot
of stored energy I'm gonna work off this
for a while I'm gonna try to make it as
late in the day as possible I learned
that from Ray so I generally don't eat
till noon or after and I kind of subsist
off one really good meal a day I just
don't eat that much like and so and what
I do eat all plant-based
right lost like 50 pounds came off yeah
it was pretty I mean easy considering
that it wasn't like I had to [ __ ] you
know pulling up truck tires in the
CrossFit studio like literally was just
giving up animal food product and I had
a cheerleader and as much as the kid now
it's to live in a household where
everyone was everywhere the kids vegan
but everyone else was vegetarian so I
was the last like holdout and you know I
I was like aw I'm gonna miss Turkey and
[ __ ] mash cuz I love that [ __ ] but I I
don't I don't miss it like I don't miss
anything
I don't miss milk which I used to drink
a lot of and stuff there's no it's the
thing that people have a hard time
wrapping their heads around they think
you're lying when you say that you're
not you don't crave those things she's
fine she changes you find new [ __ ] to
like think about you probably don't eat
the same exact [ __ ] you ate as a kid
like your taste buds mature and you find
something else you stick with that for a
while so for me
like I was never a big burger guy but
like in this world if you really want
one you can get a beyond burger and get
a you know incredible burger and stuff
like that it's it's not a lot of people
think about what am I gonna have to give
up but you got to think about what
you're gonna gain and you know I'm
pretty sure unless I get hit by a bus or
[ __ ] struck by lightning or home
invaded and [ __ ] slaughtered
I'm probably gonna live longer based on
the choices that I'm making now so when
you go in I'm assume you're going in for
regular checkup with your cardiology I
haven't okay yeah the last time I went
in with dr. Leighton I'm was come up
four months ago he's like I don't need
to see you until February cuz like what
he's again next time I say he was
February I was like that's the one year
anniversary of the heart attack you guys
that's what I'm gonna see you on same
day he was looking at when I started
with Ray he was like I don't like the
sound of this this sounds weird and I
was like well I'm doing it man and so I
kept seeing dr. late and I'm like twice
a week and he was doing my vitals and my
tests and my labs and stuff like that
and he's like you know what keep going
this is great whatever you're doing is
working he's like cholesterol levels
coming way down it's like your nutrition
levels are high Tate has got everything
you need almost yeah that's it that's
what people don't realize like it's
actually pretty nutritious yeah food
they everyone's got that protein tip but
like where you get your protein man and
it's like well it's a plant and if I mix
this with something else it'll turn into
but likes got a lot of good stuff right
here so yeah it it does now it has not
been difficult I hope anyone out there
that's like I've been thinking about
corn plant-based or I wonder if
plant-based away from me you know what
you give up in like um eating a
hamburger and I like the way this tastes
or I'm eating some turkey or I'm
drinking some milk you get back in like
oh my god I'm [ __ ] as thin as I was
in high school like you know I didn't do
this by working out I literally just did
it by kept it off coming up on that year
and so it's doable kids like you know
and and I think the heart attack has
given me nice like I've always had the
platform but it's giving me a chance to
tell people useful [ __ ] not just like I
love this movie and it'll make you feel
good too now I can impart [ __ ] like hey
man this is what worked for me I ain't
telling you to go vegan but like if you
like the way I look and saying like wow
you lost a lot of weight there it is
there's an easy way for you to do it man
I'm gonna show you the path and you just
have to give up a little but you get
back so [ __ ] much and you know that's
nothing for me I was going by the path
of like I gotta save my life
my kid is vegan because she's like I
want save the lives of others so she's a
compassionate vegan she's all about the
animals and stuff
selfishly I was all about me but now
with enough distance of course now it's
like you know start to open up to that
oh my god like I feel so [ __ ] silly
for being programmed from such a young
age but what else are you gonna tell us
like you as you sat there as a kid and
be like but wait a second we love the
dog why do we eat the cow no like wow
that's cuz God made it that way you know
they just they throw that [ __ ] on God
and then you just kind of move on but
now I'm you know forty eight and a vegan
and you know maybe not as as god-fearing
as I was as a kid this is kind of easy
to see that like there's a and I gotta
wanna Gabby so care because you don't
trigger people people get triggered duck
[ __ ] you vegans and [ __ ] like that
it's not about that but like I've seen
no difference between me and the dog I
see no difference between me and the cow
other than the fact that I could tell a
very good story that's what makes me
feel like a scam artist that's what
makes humanity feel like a scam
like we just
this one [ __ ] thing we're fast
talkers and because of that we don't get
eaten
it seems so [ __ ] unfair you know what
I'm saying like look into the eyes of a
cow look into the eyes of a [ __ ] lamb
of a turkey for Christ's sakes living
breathing individual with a soul on
inarguably there's a soul at work there
but because we tell stories and they
can't and I'm not just talking about
literally Tong stories like once upon a
time and I'm not talking about just
literally using your voice because
animals could do that too but we've you
know all bought into this story of like
you know these animals are friends and
some of these animals are meant to be
eaten and that's that's why they're here
that's how I do it because that's what
we have to do to live it's a little bit
of like a blue pill red pill matrix
moment yes because once you make the
switch and what you've experienced and I
certainly experienced is you get to the
other side of it you're like wait I was
told like I kind of had to do all that
stuff yeah it sucks nobody wants to see
animals suffer but like that's what you
got a to to live and I'm here to survive
and you'd and then you're like I
actually feel better I weigh what I
weighed in high school I feel good all
my blood markers everything's better yes
like wait what are we doing it's that
story we've been telling that's what you
like value even helps my example people
are gonna like be like oh alright
like because that's it it's never gonna
come through altruism or compassion or
empathy mine didn't mine came from self
service like hey I want to save my life
that's how you get people and if you
know if there are people at death's door
it's very easy to get them like amen
go vegan and [ __ ] but you don't want
wait that long so what you do is live by
example so you know when people like
[ __ ] man you look good what happened you
know I want vegans like get the [ __ ] out
of here like yeah yeah yeah be good man
I just dropped all the animal products I
didn't have to do anything it just kind
of fell off of me and [ __ ] like that
people are kind of they want the easiest
solution the quickest easiest solution
to all their problems and that is the
quickest easiest solution to all of your
health problems go vegan it's that
simple just go green go plant-based I
swear to you it will fix so many things
if not everything that's no dodge as no
hustle
that's the flat-out straight-up plain
[ __ ] truth right so if you can pass
that on to people like you know in my
work early on
realize that an audience and I realized
some of that audience weren't very
enlightened they were like I was like I
was kid you like guy kissing gay people
oh [ __ ] like that
I was lucky out of gay brother man so I
got to kind of face all that stuff early
on right so when I'm making art now and
I realize I got this audience that's
like if gay people suddenly I'm like
yeah I could whip it a little [ __ ]
wisdom in there a little enlightenment
like George Carlin always said best time
to reach people is when they're laughing
that's when they're most open to
suggestion that's when you can implant a
new idea so I'll trust you because they
release it was like most people are
always tight in life when they're
laughing that's when you see a true
individual who they really [ __ ] are
cuz they're no longer putting up their
guard there's like ha ha ha that's the
best time to hit him with a new idea so
in my work I started making jokes about
like [ __ ] of my main characters
wanting to suck dick just make people
comfortable with like gay references and
stuff like that and that was that wasn't
even altruistic that was cuz my brother
is gay and I was like well I hope I
don't want him to sit through these
breeder movies and be bored I got throw
a little content and for him and stuff
but then you realize you're in a
position to enlighten some cats and if
they like your [ __ ] I'm gonna take your
ideas a little more seriously and stuff
so I honestly believe that I gotta wake
up bodies behind me who are smarter than
before we met or at least a little more
enlightened based on the work I've done
and granted that's crazy cuz you look at
the work I've done and like came in
didn't your movie have a rubber [ __ ]
monster in it but you could still
backdoor enlighten people which sounds
way more sexy than I meant it while
making people laugh and stuff like that
so same thing with this [ __ ]
same thing with veganism like Jay and
Silent Bob reboot I had to do a new
draft of the script because the old
draft was all fat jokes and now I'm like
well it can't tell those because it
ain't gonna make sense so now they're
all [ __ ] vegan jokes and I'm putting
it in the work man like now I'll hit
some people and I know this by
experience by what I put in the work
before and I've watched the trickle-down
effect so I'm putting that in the work
now there's a lot of vegan stuff in Jay
and Silent Bob reboot I guarantee you
imma flip some people you know and not
in a way where I'm bragging about it but
like it's just gonna hit their ears in
the right way coming in you know in in
the middle of a movie or there's
something like that yeah it's clear to
look at me and go like well [ __ ] there's
a result there and if they're one of
those people
that wants to like you know drop some of
their weight it's gonna be a an option
and once there they're doing it they're
gonna realize they don't need to go back
like yeah it's like Jackie said before
you accept thanks cuz like that's just
the way it is way it's always been and
then when you step out the matrix when
you step out the box and [ __ ] suddenly
you're like oh there's a completely
different way to be and you know it's a
useful lesson to learn because you can
take it in to anything I was having a
notes call the other day about this
project we're working on and the guy you
know on the other end of the phone like
said some [ __ ] triggered me not in a
shitty way but just like you know
looking for changes like well maybe we
do something else
and and you know my first instinct was
like no this is what we're doing like
this is the story you can't [ __ ]
change that like that's the story the in
order for everything else to happen this
needs to happen this way and then I
started thinking about like no it's not
it's a [ __ ] story you make it up as
you go along so this guy's point is
valid you getting change it to that the
only reason you're not gonna change it
is because you're being willful and you
don't want to your attachment you know
go of the ego let go of the attachment
and you'll find a whole better place to
live it's it makes me sad not mad but
there are a lot of people online who
whenever I put up sound a bell like yeah
I'm a beginner or whatnot you get my kid
goes through it a lot chill put up
something about compassion for animals
and being a vegan and you know [ __ ]
you got a bunch of people in the
comments going well now are me now I
mean twice as much [ __ ] meat cuz of
you number one that's not true like
they're not really gonna go out and eat
twice as much as me packed is they
probably won't even eat meat that day
they're just being shitty for the sake
of being shitty but my point is like hey
man you want to go out and eat more meat
that's fine I'll see you in the I'll see
you in hell and not because you're a bad
person but just like you're gonna die
man there's you're gonna die like Meat
Is Murder and in two ways and I don't
just mean like you're killing an animal
and I ain't being political about this
so if you're sitting there going [ __ ]
you I like to eat hamburgers keep eating
hamburgers but there's some weird notion
once you get separated from it about
like so wait we kill something I put
killed things into my body and somehow
that's good for me like what am I
looking for protein okay where are those
things that I'm killing and eating
getting it they're getting them from
play
it's why the [ __ ] down I just eat the
[ __ ] plants man because then yeah
this [ __ ] may taste tasty but you know
what you know what I like more than a
burger all the [ __ ] I put on a burger I
like bread I like ketchup and all sorry
Q so I can eat that [ __ ] without a
burger and breathing ya as well so like
it's you know I'm I can't I I'm not
trying to convert people not telling you
to leave behind your childhood some
people have real romantic notions about
eating meat like because it's tied in
with eating their family at meals and
[ __ ] like that my dad used to barbecue
and my mom made a pot roast and her
chicken was and I get it I get it but
separate from it you're gonna be much
better you have all those memories like
Penn said in his book he's like look
he ate pizza once with the [ __ ] Lou
Reed and he's like you know rest of my
life I'm trying to find a slice as good
as the pizza with Lou Reed but guess
what it's never gonna happen because it
was about that experience it was about
sitting down Lou Reed and [ __ ] pizza
so I'll look for the rest of my life
trying to replicate that experience by
eating pizza it's never gonna happen so
I can let pizza go I've had the best
pizza pizza I've ever got my wife I eat
it with [ __ ] Lou Reed so everything
else now is just kind of a waste of time
once you start looking at it like that
as opposed to just what you were raised
with like here man eat three times a day
that's what you do these are the basic
instructions were given as kids three
times a day and eat [ __ ] meat you
need meat meat meat you grow and [ __ ]
and vegetables were always part of it
but very small part of it so now it's
just different you flip the script and
honestly life is better I don't say that
and any sort of like boy I'm pulling one
over on him like it's just that simple
yeah and I think it's important for
people to understand that we're we're
malleable you know we're not set in
stone so when people say well you know
this is what I like you know this is I
need this my body's telling it's like
that [ __ ] changes then you're allowed to
change it and guess what let's say you
[ __ ] love eating meat love it but
you're willing to [ __ ] take this
journey you're like wow I'm [ __ ]
maybe my health or whatever [ __ ]
reason I'm here to tell you meats never
going away it's not like why you [ __ ]
give up meat suddenly all the meat in
the world is gonna disappear New York
[ __ ]
get to have my last but do you know that
thing where you're like now that you
don't eat meat anymore you're like oh
wait people still do that yeah and not a
shitty way where I'm judging them but
I'm just like oh yeah that's right
there's that you know and every once in
a while I bring so like I eat a veggie
grill every [ __ ] day in my life
dude you have people bring you veggie
girl in the Chicago Airport I love it
the when I'll bring I'll bring non
vegans or non vegetarians with me to the
restaurant and stuff and they'll eat
there and I'm like it is great and
they're like bro you forgot what cheese
really tastes like I'm like that's fine
because this counts this is my cheese
yeah it's been it's been really good I
know complaints I honestly knock would
don't see myself ever backsliding I'm
not as militant as my kid my kid will
and believe me I'm militant enough to do
no animal products whatsoever but my
kids the kind of person that's like in
order to make this thing they filter it
through a bone that was once in an
animal so I'm not gonna eat that thing
this has honey in it honey is stolen
from a bee so I'm not gonna do that my
kid goes to the extremes so you know I'm
like kiddo I you know I'm I'm okay with
taking bunny honey from a bee
I know until they tell us it's wrong or
bad if that's if it outs that that is
what's been destroying the bee community
and not cellphones the fact that we've
been taking honey all this time then
I'll definitely god bless her man
she's got a good heart dude and that's
not to kiddie area she wasn't really
what you're in I know I'm excited at the
possibility but Scott next year I do
want to point out though like that kid
big fat compassionate heart was not
raised with one iota of religion
I was so it makes sense when I'm
empathetic and stuff because I was told
from a young age that Jesus and blah
blah blah but this kid her mother
wouldn't let her go near church he's a
guy and let her join any organization
won't let her is not a function of
doctrine it's not in the least this
kid's got bigger heart than most
collecting Catholics that I went to Mass
with throughout most of my life man
she's got more empathy for human beings
and other living things particularly the
small further things than most people
I've ever met and that didn't come from
a holy place but it did it didn't come I
shouldn't say it didn't come from a
religious place but came from a holy
place she considers things sacred even
though she
not a part of some organization that
says this is this and that is that you
could find spirituality in its life
don't have to adhere to or subscribe to
or fit into the boxes that anyone else
is put in front of you my parents I love
them to death but you know their parents
said this is what you do and then they
passed it on to us and stuff and
thankfully my wife broke the chain you
know she was like look I I don't believe
in that stuff and I don't I don't want
you forcing that on my kid if she wants
to grow up and embrace that that'll be a
choice for her one day and I always told
my wife I was like man you know really
you don't raise a kid with religion
they're gonna grow up and they've become
a Jesus Freak because the pendulum goes
swing the other way and she never did
but she's a really wonderful person with
more empathy than most quote/unquote
Christians that I know so I feel like my
wife was right let's keep her out of it
man like because that kid developed just
fine better than [ __ ] most people
that go through that organization that I
went through which again ain't me
[ __ ] on the organization I know
they've done a lot of good as Dora clean
stuff we all know they've got fault yeah
well there's a divine design to this the
child becomes the teacher
yes and you've you've that's what I had
a kid so she would teach me to save my
life I'm that stupid it's a it's a comic
book it is you know you're your own
superhero in this narrative but you made
a conscious decision to kind of shoulder
this this mantle of sharing this
experience you could have been quietly
kind of doing this but not you know
taking advantage of the microphone in
front of you to speak to this it helps
keep you honest if everybody's going
through the journey with you and knows
your intention so there I was telling
people like I'm going vegan you know
that you got to put it out there and
suddenly and everyone you meet
afterwards they see you eating any meat
they're like bro I thought you went
vegan aren't you a big and bro so soon
you know that's the first part you got
to throw your hat over the wall name it
and claim it and stuff so that's me
going I'm gonna do this and then losing
the weight I kept sharing it because
well a it's evident but be that kind of
support people going you look good like
that makes you want to keep going and
stuff like that but also I'm just a
Content person like you know I do as so
many podcast Moi's on stage some we're
talking trying to write [ __ ] I need
content and that's a big part of my life
for me to ignore that or not
share with others would like that make
me a poor storyteller like I'd be
leaving a big fat pointed arrow right in
the quiver and stuff so being able to
talk about that is good it also like
you're hitting people like just on the
business level you're hitting people you
don't normally hit you're getting people
listening to you who wouldn't give a
[ __ ] about the work you do like clerks
oh that's not for me but they see me on
Colbert talking about the heart attack
and they're like oh [ __ ] that's
interesting oh I like this guy he's
being honest a mother blah so it gives
me another opportunity to find an
audience and help an audience and those
are you know one is an altruistic thing
I want to help people I want to be of
service in this life there's nothing
more beautiful than living in service of
others but I'm also selfish and sand you
know self-involved so it's like what do
I get out of this right well in the art
project that is Kevin Smith and his life
this is just another story though that's
it and oddly enough hopefully knock wood
you know in a couple years the heart
attack is just background noise like
hopefully I don't have another one i
swatched that movie vais about dick
cheney last night who knew that dude
have like [ __ ] 19 heart attacks and
I'm like oh my god I want to go that
route so yeah hopefully until the next
heart attack and hopefully there's a
never one never another one like this
might just hopefully my life keeps being
interesting or I do enough [ __ ] where
the heart attack is just like oh yeah
any else had a heart attack once but you
don't want it to ever define you like he
made clerks and then he had a heart
attack and that's all he is from now on
but share it like and the walrus movie
yes there's that a lot of people assume
I had the heart attack because of the
probably but like you want nuts and it's
heart broke but yeah man sharing it like
hey I can't help it but B if others can
get something out of it that's wonderful
that's the idea all right man well let's
wind this down in terms of other people
getting something out of it if
somebody's listening to this and they're
they are inspired by your story in your
example like man I don't want to have a
heart attack but you know I'm a little
bit intimidated by this leap of faith
into the big V you know you don't want
to have a heart attack
the big V is the easiest way to not have
a heart attack that I've seen and I've
had nutritionists say
as well an event doctors I mean look you
won't find a doctor that'll tell you
like being vegan that ain't gonna help
like you know there's some doctors like
dr. Leighton hon who saved my life was
like you don't need to give up meat
there's nothing wrong with little meat
in your life and I'm like fat that's
awesome good to hear my kid was mad
about that she was just like how dare he
is a doctor I was like that doctor just
saved my life she's like but he's
telling you good eat meat still I was
like because he's right I could if I
wanted to wouldn't necessarily kill me
it doesn't kill people but I'm not going
to that's a choice I'm making and stuff
and you know you want you want others to
realize that as well it's possible and
if you're worried about your body if
you're worried about your health and
stuff you know on two levels if you're
worried that oh my god I look like [ __ ]
going vegan is gonna help that and if
you're more worried rightfully so about
I wonder what the [ __ ] is going on
inside my body something we rarely think
about cuz we don't see it right you know
what the inner workings are and stuff
it's good for that as well
it's like nothing bad comes out of this
unless what you think as bad as all but
I get a give up [ __ ] turkey chicken
steak whatever the [ __ ] you know
sometimes in life you give up something
you get back so much more I'm not you
know we've talked about religion and the
Bible and stuff and while I you know but
that particular feelings about how
people use that book I do like that book
quite a bit it's full of great [ __ ]
useful tips and [ __ ] like that and one
of the things that somebody said in the
Bible was whatever you give out comes
back to you Sevenfold
you know and when they set it back then
people took it literally like alright
I'm gonna give you a dollar and give me
seven bucks but it's figuratively it's
what you put out you get back what you
put out there into the [ __ ] world and
stuff so I like to put this out there in
the world if it gives somebody a chance
to maybe rectify their [ __ ] and change
and make their journey a little bit
longer or start their journey where it
makes them go like this is the [ __ ] like
you know I had no idea that being a
vegan brings the poet out in you you
never know like think about it if you're
standing there gone yeah that all sounds
good but change is [ __ ] hard and
stuff you've changed before we're human
beings man we're so very capable of
[ __ ] change but do what I did like if
you're really sick
there and you're like I don't know
except the heart attack part yeah skip
that
just give it [ __ ] a year give it six
months just tell yourself like look I've
done whatever I've wanted to do for my
whole [ __ ] life
let me try being a vegan for six months
you see if I could do it take it as a
personal challenge and [ __ ] at the end
of that six months if you want to go
back to eating meat god bless go ahead
chances are you will see such a positive
[ __ ] impact such improbable change
that you've never experienced by all the
other ways you've tried to get to this
root and stuff that you may just stay
that's what I did I'm still here and
I'll stay because I'm like I can't argue
with the [ __ ] results and also I'm
not I don't want to just make it about
result-oriented [ __ ] I eat tastes good
I'm satisfied I'm not sitting there
going man I have to do without I eat a
lot of tasty things yeah it's not
martyrdom no you know it's martyrdom
smart I like that thank you I'm gonna
steal I'm a writer alright super
inspiring man did you get anything out
of it you got a [ __ ] you got this down
to a science like you wanna do it a
little bit longer than you yes I mean
you know I had a I had a similar
transformation and that transformation
was not just physical it was mental
emotional and spiritual and it continues
it always is you need to learn and I'm
not a perfect human being and I'm flawed
and I [ __ ] up and I'm an [ __ ] and all
of then humanity writ large but I will
vouch for what you said which is there
is a transformation that takes place
when you remove these things from your
plate and what that boils down to I
can't say is it is it you know something
beyond the senses I don't know you know
all I know is I feel better
i Function better change my life change
what I do for a living senses you mean
like like there is not taking life like
you know has have you had you know what
is your spiritual perspective right I I
believe that when I and this sounds
crazy and you can call me crazy I don't
care but like when you were it and it's
part of the Sevenfold thing like when
you remove violence I agree with you
completely there is an emotional and
spiritual
affect or impact yeah that has had on me
III would agree with that 100% and I've
always been a fairly empathetic person
with a deep deep abiding love for
animals but and I do this I'm not your
daughter I didn't get into it to see me
neither I never thought that that would
be important to me her that I would care
but it's kind of weird that it's like I
mean this sounds kooky and and you know
artsy but like there's something to be
said for removing blood from your life
it washes clean like and I'm not I try
to make people - I don't think you re
they're going to try and make people
feel guilty and stuff like that but like
there's a pretty [ __ ] a horrific step
that goes between a living creature in
your stomach and you know we got a bunch
a lot of you there's a lot of effort
that goes into preventing you from
connecting with that truth yeah and
seeing how far would all this and
thinking about it like I was told as a
kid like I'll wash you know that's God
made it that way no that ain't look I'm
not sure there's an existence of God to
begin with but if there is a God a damn
Skippy no he didn't come up with the
meat industry so yeah you're right there
is a certain consciousness that comes
along with it and doesn't may make one
better but it just
well it's honestly physically it does
make one better it doesn't make you a
better person than somebody else just
means you got into someplace that a lot
of people can get to if they're willing
to take a step it's like that hand in
the Box like right put the monkeys guy's
hand box holding on over banana and you
can't escape the box and all the monkey
has to do is let go of the banana and
they post hand out of the box
everybody's holding onto that banana and
[ __ ] you and me let go and we let go for
different reasons we didn't even do it
altruistic it wasn't even like man I'm
gonna be a better human but we found
ourselves being better because of it
because of simple choices we made to
save our own lives and I stand in
judgment of nobody me neither I
certainly don't feel like I'm better
than anybody else any kind of pedestal
and it is I do physically feel brother
far from it for me to tell anybody how
to live their life right you share
possibly experience actly
that's it take from it what you would
like discard the rest and be your own
experiment in an end of
you know try it like you said six months
thirty days one week whatever it is and
see for yourself
give more than a week though yeah
anybody could do yeah that's like Lent
like give it give it I like how you said
six months I think that's a commitment
that's a man of two and it also the six
you need six months to change the brain
chemistry on anything but if you're an
alcoholic it through a romance like
that's gone bad or ended or some six
months is how you change your mindset so
if you take if you do it for two months
you know you may be like oh this is good
but I still like this oh [ __ ] six months
gives you enough distance is enough time
and enough body purification where
suddenly you will be thinking a little
more clearly but but again I'm not
this isn't about like we're right and
you're wrong this is just what we've
both experienced and we're just passing
that on and if it helps you oh my god
welcome to the party and stuff and if
you don't hear it now maybe you hear it
two years from now maybe you hear it
after you've been on the [ __ ] table
and stuff like that it's never too late
until it is too late but give it a shot
don't leave this world without [ __ ]
trying six months I'm doing something
that you never thought you could do hey
you'll prove something to yourself you
prove yourself that you're stronger
individual than you ever possibly
imagined and B you could drastically and
vastly change your life in a positive
way and very few thing you know you
watch TV and they're always selling you
the opportunity of changing your life
and stuff like that this is this don't
cost you anything and some people I got
it's expensive to eat healthy [ __ ]
doesn't have to be it's cheaper you know
to eat healthy like I'm not saying like
Whole Foods yes you know they've
definitely charged more than the average
bear but you ain't got a shop just there
and if you're reducing the amount you
eat anyway it's gonna be cheaper period
I'm telling you it's all connected
you're gonna have more money you're
gonna feel better in life it's crazy the
positives that come out of being a vegan
the only negative is every once in a
while somebody who's not a vegan it's
like [ __ ] you vegan yes every day
somebody's I haven't scrolled through
your app mentions but I get a few a
little bit of that most people are
they're kinder to me so more like hey
bro
more meat for me I'm like I'm let's say
you want to deal with a plan they can
have it
thank you for having me and I rarely get
to talk about health it's so I
appreciate for dialog meats are super
inspiring that they can cool piece base
that was it we did it Kevin Smith ladies
and gentlemen did you guys enjoyed that
I really liked that guy that is an
incredibly powerful and inspiring story
let Kevin know what you thought of
today's exchange by hitting him up on
Twitter or Instagram at that Kevin Smith
he's also pretty active on Facebook as
well facebook-dot-com forward-slash yes
that Kevin Smith I guess is his page
there and you could check out his many
podcasts at SModcast calm and keep an
eye out for the new Jay and Silent Bob
reboot movie which is being filmed right
now I think it's coming out in October
if you are struggling with your diet in
the way that Kevin once was if you're
really desiring of finally mastering
your plate but feel like you don't have
the skill in the kitchen or the time I
cannot stress enough how much I know for
a fact our play a power meal planner can
help you it truly is an extraordinary
product we work very hard to create and
it solves a very simple basic problem
making nutritious eating convenient and
delicious when you sign up at meals dot
rich roll com you get access to
thousands of plant-based recipes you get
grocery lists and grocery delivery and
most metropolitan areas you get access
to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week and right now we got a
special deal a special offer $20 off
through April 13th when you use the code
power 20 at checkout so check it out
meals dot rich roll calm or click on
meal planner on the top menu on my
website rich roll calm if you'd like to
support the work we do here on the
podcast there are a couple simple ways
to do that just tell your friends about
it share the enthusiasm take a screen
grab of it and share it on your favorite
social media platform tag me subscribe
to the show on Apple podcasts on YouTube
on Google podcasts on Spotify Spotify
making waves in the podcast space and
you can support us on patreon at rich
roll com forward slash donate I want to
thank everybody who helped put on the
show today
Jason cami yellow for audio engineering
productions show notes interstitial
music Blake Curtis and Margo Lubin who
usually typically film and edit the
podcast but today's exchange with Kevin
was audio
only so look forward to the next episode
to get back to YouTube
Jessica Miranda for her beautiful
graphics and visual imagery that
accompanies the show DK my man David
Kahn advertiser relationships Thank You
DK he's sitting right across me he's not
saying anything you're welcome
theme music as always by analemma thanks
for the love you guys see you back here
in a couple days with another highly
anticipated hotly anticipated episode
with my man guru Singh another episode
of guru corner until that piece plants
namaste namaste
[Music]